So
Let's go
oder auch nicht
Ziemlich kaputt heute er ich weiß ich mache letztes nutz nur streams wo ich ziemlich kaputt bin
mag wahrscheinlich auch an der uhrzeit liegen
dass die letzte mal nur abends online gewesen mein bot partner bot trick ich habe bot patrick gelesen erst
Aber das ist ja nun wirklich ganz vorbei
ja mal gucken leute also
Ich habe nicht so wirklich mir was überlegt für heute ich habe
also eine sache könnte man vielleicht basteln
ansonsten ich ich müsste auch noch ein bisschen technik kram kaufen bei aliexpress beziehungsweise vielleicht auch mal bei amazon gucken
Ansonsten ach michael 50 billionen am start moin danke für den sub
und
7l qs
Wie auch immer nicht weiß nicht so genau aber dafür den sub
bettelbett schon gezockt ja schon lange
Ich habe sogar die playtest nicht alle aber viele playtest gespielt
Ach lars ja gut wenn man das weiß
Patrick pock mister amerik jetzt denn jetzt los hier jetzt ist der scam train am start
schnelle überweisung zu besos ist raus moin max
Und was meinst du zu bettelbett
Ja also das habe ich da habe ich die frage kommt ja nicht zum ersten mal im stream also
ich weiß ja schon
Dass euch das interessiert also meine meinung zu bettelbett zumindest das letzte mal wo ich gespielt war war
Also ich glaube nicht dass das der große battlefield killer wird wie sie sich das alle immer vorstellen das ist aber auch nicht
Das steht auch nicht zur debatte weil das macht da ist schon selbst
Eindrucksvoll bewiesen dass der größte battlefield killer da ist selbst ist naja aber was denke ich zu bettelbett also ich muss dir ehrlich sagen ich mag den
Mal kurz das im auge ein bisschen weg
Also ich muss ehrlich sagen ich mag den grafikstil nicht ich habe nix wie gesagt für mit super nintendo spielen und sowas aufgewachsen ich
habe nichts gegen minimalistische grafik oder gar pixel grafik
Aber ich finde die maps sind einfach nur leer das siehst du auch in den häusern die sind auch
Gameplay technisch finde ich nicht sonderlich gut aufgebaut
Du weißt beispielsweise gar nicht wo man jetzt von einer seite zur anderen rüber kommt gut
Ist insofern nicht ganz so wild weil das hatten halbwegs brauchbare zerstörung system
aber trotzdem
Die häuser sind extrem leer ich finde die maps sind einfach nur leer
Aber trotzdem
Die häuser sind extrem leer gänge sind leer schatten würfe erkennst du gar nicht um tunnel weitergehen um tunnel aufhört
also die maps sind also vom gameplayer finde ich eigentlich für early access
beziehungsweise damals in den playtests ganz okay wenn auch noch sehr auf schienen oftmals aber
Die die der detailgrad der maps und der grafikstil gefällt mir nicht
Und das sage ich als jemand der eigentlich ich mag eigentlich pixel grafik
Aber in dem fall gefällt es mir nicht wirklich gut twitter ist komplett tot ja das habe ich auch mitgekriegt
Ich habe auf twitter twitterfreund die nachricht gekriegt
Irgendwas ganz bescheuert das habe ich noch nie sonst so
Sonstwo gesehen ihr aufruf limit ist erreicht oder sowas habe ich jetzt
Was was wollt ihr von mir keine ahnung was für ein aufruf limit
Aber gut twitter
Wer die werden schon wissen aber
Also ich denke nicht dass elon musk persönlich gesagt hat lass mal twitter abschalten
Twitter hat ja durchaus auch das eine oder andere mal schon kleine
Kleine zucker so
Bevor er das ganze gekauft hat natürlich ich muss sagen es hat sich viel verändert für mich als twitter user selbst
Also ich habe weder nen abo dort und auch noch sonst was sagen für mich als user
Es ist zwar auch ein bisschen anders aber ich finde immer noch dass twitter
Was social media angeht die beste plattform ist wenn auch gerade auf twitter so dieses social media
Circle jerk business noch am ausgeprägt ist also eigentlich eine sache die mich ultra aufregt
Sagen silber auch am start
Es ist heute ist erster deswegen gibt es die ganzen primes ab
Alle alle alle bei den zapser ist absehen ausgelaufen
Woran woran liegt es leute
Selbstverständlich weiß nicht auf was du durch was beziehst du dich
Also wie jetzt was jetzt für was 6000 was man darf demnächst wird er noch mit account benutzen
Das kann ich mir jetzt aber kaum vorstellen oder
Guck mal mal kurz guck mal in die news ob ich irgendwas vielleicht noch verpasst habe
Was mit twitter zusammenhängt
News twitter schließt offenbar nutzer ohne account was zum
Okay ich meine
Okay, das ist dann jetzt der allererste move
Der mich soweit betrifft dass ich sagen würde
Wenn das so kommt benutzt kein twitter mehr
Die anderen sachen habe ich ein bisschen argwöhnlich begutachtet mir gedacht na gut wer weiß
Aber okay wer einen link auf einen tweet oder auf einen twitter profit landet nun nicht mehr am gewünscht sind auf
Seriously
Das ist ja hängen geblieben das ist da okay das ist ähnlich abfuck wie die reddit app nur dass man reddit wenigstens noch so lesen kann
Es ist zwar unusable ohne app und mit app ist es auch kacke weil die offizielle app naja
Aber so mittlerweile geht es ja halbwegs
Das kannst du echt ist das wirklich so
Ja, okay, das ist absolut hirnverbrannt
Das ist das ist mega dämlich
Ja bei instagram kannst du die seite wenigstens aufmachen und nach zweimal scrollen nervt sich dann mit account ja das ist ja mal
ultra ultra also hyper beknackt das
Das kann ich mir auch nicht vorstellen dass das dauerhaft sein wird das nimmt doch auch twitter fast schon jegliche relevanz was
Irgendwelche news oder post oder sowas angeht wenn da keiner mehr ordentlich drauf verlinken kann in irgendwelchen berichten
Ist nicht mal das schlimmste heute
Die schießen sich damit richtig ins knie
Also weil wer weiß vielleicht habe ich die geniale entscheidung dahinter noch nicht erkannt aber ich sehe es jetzt aktuell nicht
Wieso was ist denn das schlimmste heute erzähl
morris oder morris
Erzähl was ist das schlimmste
Das ist das ist ja mal richtig krass hängen geblieben alter ist das bescheuert
Der letzte tweet ok zeigt mal das da oder wie soll er denn geschrieben
Ach so ja gut ich kann ihn ja nicht aufmachen den tweet
Ich kann den tweet ja nicht aufmachen weil ich ja hier nicht eingeloggt bin
Das ist ja mal absolut bescheuert man
Ich kann den tweet übrigens auch wo ich eingeloggt bin nicht aufmachen wahrscheinlich weil ich zu viele tweets heute schon gelesen habe ok damit
Das ist wirklich der move was für mich twitter killen könnte er sagt bisher habe ich immer noch genau ok wer weiß wie sich das
Ganze so entwickelt aber das ist für mich echt ein grund twitter nicht nichts nichts
Zu also nicht mehr in dem maß zu ich werde es nicht ganz nicht benutzt aber nicht mal in dem maß zu konsumieren
wie es gedacht ist
also wie es mal
wie ich es gerne machen würde
Das sehe ich nicht ein
Ja im ernst alter das wie ich gerade gesagt habe das nimmt auch total viel relevanz von twitter weg
Weil ich würde mir bei manchen leuten wünschen dass sie nicht so viel scheiße posten können ich nicht so viel müssten mist lesen müsste
allerdings das ist ja davon gar nicht betroffen
Das ist wirklich richtig hängen geblieben also
Das hätte also den move hätte ich nicht nicht gedacht
Du kannst du kannst in irgendwelchen artikeln noch nicht mal auf was verlinken also jetzt mal ernsthaft
Ich war nie großer
Befürworter dieser geschichte mit ja dann dann gehen jetzt alle von twitter weg sondern zu irgendeiner anderen
Plattform das hat ungefähr genauso viel wie damals aber wir gehen jetzt alle zu anderen messengern oder die leute benutzen kein facebook mehr und so was
Letztendlich braucht so eine brauchen neue platz oder brauchen plattformen irgendwie die kritische masse dass das funktioniert aber
Ich meine wenn du es nicht benutzen kannst
Das ist ja dann nicht die frage mehr die leute sind zu faul auf eine neue plattform zu gehen sondern es wird ja
Gehindert es zu nutzen die funktionieren doch jetzt schon teilweise nicht mehr
jetzt schon brauchen also
Also ich vielleicht erkenne ich die genialität dieses business moves nicht aber
Da schießen sie sich ins eigene bein also
Chat das können wir nicht erzählen ich muss erst mal auf die plattformen schauen
Chat das können wir nicht erzählen moment ich muss erst mal ich muss mal kurz drüber scrollen nicht dass ich jetzt wieder eine halbe stunde hinter dem chat
hinterher bin gleich
Ja das ist richtig sad gerena winn dankeschön für den sub das ist nix
600 tweets das scrollst du zweimal und dann ist das ist es weg
zumal die twitter ja mittlerweile auch diese komische für dich empfohlen seit unterschiebt anstatt seine standard timeline
Da mal durch zu scrollen ist also das ist das das nimmt so viel das nimmt so viel relevanz auch irgendwie weg von twitter ich kann
mir nicht vorstellen warum man
Den den sinn hinter dem move verstehe nicht jetzt fuchs danke für den sub aber ich merke heute ist der erste geht es richtig zur sache
ja es ist
das erste
Das erste seriously das erste juckt doch twitter gar nicht das ist einfach nur eine vorgeschobene begründung
Ja sicherlich gibt es probleme mit bots und sicherlich gibt es auch probleme dass da irgendwelche sachen
gescraped werden oder anderweitig verwendet werden das ist aber seit jahren schon so und das ist jetzt auch
Letztendlich nix wo ich sagen würde das ist jetzt bei twitter so schlimm geht eigentlich klar bots sind ultra nerv
Nervig aber auf twitter ist eigentlich nur die plattform wo sich bots finde ich noch irgendwie am wenigsten so ins täglichen täglichen lesefluss rein drängen
Das ist einfach nur vorgeschobener grund hier für die also was sie damit erreichen wollen weiß ich nicht genau
twitter in zwei munten der ende so schnell wird das nicht wird das bestimmt nicht gehen
also das ist der punkt den ich so den ich schon öfters lese das glaube ich aber nicht sicherlich
Hat er in der vergangenheit hat sich in der mask ziemlich gebietet mit twitter in der vergangenheit ja und er hat ja twitter
übernommen allerdings muss man sagen soweit ich das soweit ich das damals verfolgt haben war das ja keine
das war nicht dass er da hingegangen ist und hat gesagt ich lege euch da jetzt ein paar millionen auf den tisch sondern
er hat quasi twitter übernommen
und twitter selbst zum großen teil irgendwie auf twitter selbst den kredit aufgenommen
um das zu bezahlen also twitter hat sich quasi selbst bezahlt für die übernahme zum größten teil so
zumindest ist das mein kenntnisstand zum damaligen zeitpunkt wo ich das bisschen mitverfolgt habe
das problem dabei ist
das kannst du ja auch nur machen
wenn dir die leute halbwegs trauen die die die die kredite geben also so dieses er hat das nur gekauft um es
kaputt zu machen ergibt doch eigentlich aus bösen sicht keinen sinn
jetzt im nachhinein gut natürlich hat man sagen können ja der wollte es ja nie er musste er wurde dann gezwungen das ganze zu übernehmen
aber trotzdem jetzt im nachhinein also ganz so wir stelle ich mir bei ihm dann doch nicht vor
und wenn du es wenn du es loswerden willst wird jetzt einfach dicht machen können
er hätte es einfach dicht machen können wenn du gar keinen bock drauf hast also
also ich meine und man muss sagen die maßnahmen die in den letzten monaten bei twitter ergriffen wurden
die kann man zwar kritisch sehen aber man kann sie zumindest auch
unter dem kontext verstehen dass irgendjemand versucht dort ein sagen wir mal halbwegs
funktionierendes
sich sich sich selbst
selbst erhalten können das business
umzubauen
man kann vielleicht sich drüber streiten ob die maßnahmen toll sind ob das alles funktioniert man konnte zumindest dahinter immer noch den plan vermuten
das sind business entscheidungen die twitter quasi
finanziell irgendwie voranbringen sollen aber das verstehe ich nicht in dem fall
damit schießen sie sich wirklich ins eigene bein
Es sei denn und man sollte sich das ja immer noch so offen halten vielleicht habe ich auch nur die genialität dieser business entscheidung nicht verstanden
aber das kann ich mir nicht nicht vorstellen das heißt ich kann morgens jetzt auf dem handy ich kann das aufs handy gehen leute
und dort zweimal zweimal scrollen
Übrigens witzigerweise auf dem handy geht alles
auf dem handy ist alles vollkommen okay also das scheint nur für desktop user zu sein
Auf dem handy bin ich mit dem gleichen account drin und kann ohne probleme scrollen und machen und tun
Vielleicht ist es tatsächlich nur wenn man von plattformen darauf zugreift wo wo er denkt dass ach ich habe keine ahnung was er denkt
Aber davon abgesehen ich kann mich einfach als ios client ausgeben das ist ja auch nicht so schwierig
Naja gut da bin ich mal gespannt wie sich das die nächsten tage entwickelt
Es wurden ja schon einige entscheidungen bei twitter mal wieder
reverted
Also das ist jetzt wirklich die erste entscheidung wo ich sage mit der kann ich twitter eigentlich gar nicht mehr richtig benutzen
Na ja nee das will ich nicht es macht es macht ja auch keinen sinn nur weil an manche plattformen auf den sack gehen
Alle sachen
Komplett zu ignorieren ich meine guck mal und vor allem warum reddit warum reddit ich meine wir haben früher auch foren gelesen
Ja und auch ultra kack toxic forum foren
so das microcontroller forum
Oder das freelance forum das sind so meine zwei lieblings beispiele wenn es um toxic foren geht aber
Es macht ja auch keinen sinn zu sagen ich ignoriere das alles es gibt für mich
Übersicht
administrator punkt.de ja und solche sachen fachinformatiker punkt wobei das war eigentlich ganz da wird bloß wie blödsinn
Da wird viel blödsinn geschrieben aber das war nicht toxic es gibt aber wohl keinen besseren überblick und um schneller sachen
Raus zu bekommen wie twitter und reddit twitter ist für aktuelle geschehnissen einfach immer noch nach wie vor das beste was es gibt
Keine news seiten oder irgendwas kommt an twitter ran
Also wenn ich mal irgendwie in frankfurt bin und da rennt einer mit mit dem maschinengewehr durch die straße
Das erfahre ich auf twitter
Bevor ich irgendwo anders erfahre dass ich jetzt besser nicht zum hauptbahnhof laufen sollte oder sowas das habe ich auf twitter schneller mitgekriegt
Als überall anders
Wahrscheinlich schneller als irgendwelche waren dinger für irgendwelche handys abgesetzt werden können also twitter ist zu mitbekommen von aktuellen sachen einfach
Das beste was es gibt was halt komplett dadurch unterkramen wird wenn du nur wenn du den tweet limit hast ja
Richtig hängen geblieben da willst du dann reingucken gerade und so geht halt nicht mehr weil es irgendwie
Morgen schon ein bisschen zu viel gescrollt hast
6000 tweets sind übrigens auch nicht allzu viele so und reddit ist nach wie vor das beste wenn man sich über bestimmte themen
Also
Okay, das muss ich anders erklären twitter ist halt super für news und und aktuelle themen reddit ist auch super für aktuelle themen wenn
man ein bisschen den kontext drumherum haben will und auch so ein bisschen wissen will okay
Wie sehen das die leute und wie kommen sachen so an beispielsweise irgendein neuer patch für battlefield kommt raus ja da ist reddit
Einfach das beste da mal rein zu gucken und da siehst du schon gleich okay dozer shield op über battlefield und so was danke schön
Patrick ich merke heute ist der erste
Danke für den sub
also
Okay, whatsapp kann ich dir gebe ich dir recht whatsapp verwendet ja auch nicht aber aber twitter und reddit sind beide in ihren bereichen eigentlich das beste
Da da warte ich ja noch drauf da gab es doch letztens auch irgendwas
Und und wobei haben sie das jetzt nicht abgesagt
Irgendwas ich habe so am rande mitgekriegt dass ich
Zuckerberg und Elon Musk irgendwie kloppen wollten das wäre was das würde ich mir tatsächlich angucken
Die könnten das doch im metaverse übertragen oder
Und da würde der würde der zug auch gleich sehen wie wahnsinnig beliebt das metaverse ist weil sie da nur fünf zuschauer hätten
Elon's Mutter ja stimmt stimmt da war irgendwas
Ja, das ist noch so ein ding was ich nicht verstehe
Weniger tweets weniger user weniger werbe das ergibt einfach irgendwie keinen sinn
Daran haben sie aber versucht was zu ändern in letzter zeit zumindest konnte man sich das so zurecht reiben anhand der neuen versuche
Ich fand auch vieles nicht sonderlich sinnig
Gerade das verifizierte accounts auf einmal ausgesehen haben wie die alten also okay das häkchen ist ein bisschen anders
Aber irgendwelche random leute waren das war alles nicht so richtig durchdacht aber man konnte es zumindest noch so
Darunter zusammenfassen okay die versuchen halt welcher welches business irgendwie möglich ist aber das jetzt macht überhaupt keinen sinn
Also bei mir geht es zurzeit dauerhaft auf meinem
Ohne account nicht aber mit ios mit der ios app und eingeloggt habe ich überhaupt kein problem
Ich glaube nicht dass sie das aufrechterhalten werden
okay, also
Endofunction bist noch da
Ich erkläre das jetzt mal weil ich habe ja heute ich habe ja heute im video gesagt
Ich hätte nicht gedacht dass leute in stream kommen tatsächlich fragen
Aber ich habe tatsächlich auch ein paar follower gekriegt nach dem video als durchaus möglich dass leute hier am start sind
Also ich habe sie im streamer schon öfters erklärt aber wenn endofunction nicht mehr da ist muss ich jetzt auch nicht erklären weiß ich
Bist du noch da oder will irgendjemand wissen was das problem mit cubectl war was ich heute im video angesprochen habe
Okay, also ich erkläre ich das mal okay ich habe es im stream schon mal erzählt
Also was ich heute im video gesagt habe ist folgendes also im im heutigen video ging es ja darum
Dass wenn man tolle sachen ganz kurz zusammengefasst wenn man tolle sachen ausgehen um dieses video hier
Nicht twitter weg wer es noch nicht gesehen hat leute
Ich brauche ich brauche ich brauche view time alle alle please video anklicken jetzt während ich erkläre ihr könnt ihr könnt auch stumm schalten
also
Ich habe im heutigen video gesagt sinngemäß ist die essenz aus dem video wenn man tolle sachen macht
Es ist aber anders es ist genauso wichtig tolle sachen zu machen wie anschließend darüber zu reden dass man tolle sachen gemacht hat
So das ist die essenz aus dem video
Und ich habe ein beispiel gebracht was gerade eben bei mir auf der arbeit angesagt war und zwar wir hatten ein problem mit cubectl
cubectl ist ein ist das offizielle command line tool für kubernetes
Da sieht man auch in der kubernetes organisation drin also sprich das offizielle command line tool um kubernetes cluster zu administrieren
Gibt noch ein paar andere tools aber cubectl ist das offizielle und eigentlich auch das was in allen tutorials steht wenn man sich mit kubernetes beschäftigt
Also kurz gesagt ein cubectl führt halt nichts führt keinen weg vorbei wenn man kubernetes administrieren will
So und wir hatten jetzt folgendes problem
Immer wenn du cubectl ausgeführt hast das erste mal am tag hing es für
Undefinierte zeit es hat sich keiner bisher die mühe gemacht das genauer anzugucken wie lang also es hing immer und dann hing es in
Und zumindest war das die fehlerbeschreibung die sie mir erzählt haben und dann hing das auch immer wieder in unregelmäßigen abständen für eine weile
So das und irgendwann ging es mir persönlich selbst so sehr auf den sack dass ich mir das mal so
1 2 3 stunden die bugt hat mir das angeguckt ich habe das durch ich habe ich habe aufrufe mit geschnitten mit
S trace habe ich mir angeguckt ich habe geschaut was unter der haube passiert options proxys gesetzt alles mögliche und irgendwann habe ich auch
Einfach mal gemessen das ist übrigens prinzipiell ein tipp den ich euch geben kann und der oftmals bei vielen sachen die unklar sind
Erkenntnis bringt das klingt nach einem wired bug nee es ist kein naja ja
Nicht so richtig ein bug ich erzähle ich erzähle euch woran es gelegen hat
Es ist ein tipp den ich euch allgemein geben kann wenn so sachen so unspezifisch sind ja so geht mal mal geht es nicht dann geht es
Für so und so lange nicht und so
Messt man nach oder versucht das irgendwie nachzustellen und nachzumessen wie viel das wirklich ist so
Und das habe ich gemacht geht übrigens ganz einfach ich kann euch das ich kann jetzt mal unter linux zeigen
Wie man wie man sowas machen kann aber kurz meine vm an
So und zwar es gibt ein cli tool
Das nennt sich timeout ich habe sie ja sogar schon mal gezeigt so das nennt sich das nennt sich timeout
Und mit timeout kannst du als das ist eine schleife den das hier ist der relevante part den rest könnte ignorieren
So und timeout setzt oder schickt muss ich mit timeout kannst du andere programme starten
So und wenn diese programme nicht innerhalb einer festgelegten zeit einer festgelegten zeit
Fertig sind dann schickt timeout ein signal an das programm so in dem fall
Starte ich den befehl sleep 5 der fünf sekunden einfach nur hängt
Mit timeout und nach zwei sekunden schicke ich ans lieb ein term signal also dass das ding
sich beenden soll
Term ist sogar glaube ich kill das dann wird es wird es aus ausgeknipst wird ausgeschaltet so
Und damit kann man ganz gut testen so ob und wie lange
Sachen hängen in welchem intervall so und ich bin und ich bin raus also das was rausgekommen ist folgendes
cubectl hängt immer
alle
15 minuten für ziemlich genau zwei minuten
so und chat
Vielleicht denkt sich jetzt jemand schon was was
Welches programm fällt euch so ein was standard was sind die was ein default timeout von zwei minuten hat und was unter linux sehr verbreitet ist
Okay, chat ist noch nicht hiq genug chat hat noch nicht genug prime subscribed ich werde es euch erzählen und zwar curl
Ja also wenn der curl ist ein commando zeilen tool wo man webseiten beziehungsweise dateien aus dem internet runterladen kann
also wenn ich jetzt sage hier curl
youtube.com sagt
Okay
Und der curl default timeout
ist
zwei minuten bin ich mir gar nicht sicher ob das in der
in der readme irgendwie drin steht
gut ist auch wurscht zumindest
habe ich rausbekommen cubectl benutzt unter der haube curl die curl library um sachen down zu laden lange rede kurzer sinn also
Alle 15 minuten hängt das immer für zwei minuten was sehr verdächtig
wie sagt man so schön
sehr verdächtiger intervall ist und auch dieser zwei minuten timeout wenn man weiß dass das unter der haube curl verwendet
klingt ganz danach ist sehr sass klingt ganz danach als ist an irgendwelchen stellen was
geblockt und zwar nicht einfach nur geblockt mit reject sondern wirklich mit drop also irgendwelche packages
so dann habe ich weiter geguckt also muss man vielleicht noch mal an der stelle erklären
der unterschied
oder chat iq test für euch noch mal was ist der unterschied zwischen paketen rejecten und pakete droppen
was hat er da jetzt runtergeladen gar nichts hat die website ausgegeben curl gibt standardmäßig auf standard aus den
das aus was er runterlädt
richtig madminister hat recht
in der das stimmt nicht
reject wird auch nicht weitergeleitet noch was ja also
Das ist das im prinzip richtig genau so sieht so sieht das ganze aus also wenn man packages droppt
mit manchen haben wir jetzt eine firewall wir stellen in der firewall ein
pakete dürfen nicht
zu dem rechner
und dann müsst ihr einstellen was mit den paketen passieren soll es gibt in der firewall keine einstellung dürfen nicht zu dem rechner ihr
müsst dann sagen packages zu dieser ip sollen getroppt werden oder sie sollen rejected werden der unterschied ist wenn pakete getroppt werden
no limit xo dankeschön 29 monate hyper subscription hier
Wenn pakete getroppt werden da werden die einfach weggeschmissen
die guckt da rein firewall regeln drop flupp paket weg das heißt der sender dieses pakets bekommt nie mit dass die dinger verworfen werden
reject bedeutet irgendeine ismp fehlermeldung zurück
Dementsprechend können programme wie köln bei einem job eigentlich nichts machen außer auf den timeout warten
weil für köln sieht das so aus als hat das paket herausgeschickt
und
dort hat einfach bis es zurückkommt er weiß ja nicht dass die verworfen wurden das heißt er wartet 120 sekunden würden diese pakete rejected werden
würde sofort in fehlermeldung kommen und köln würde das mitbekommen ok verbindung nicht möglich ich kann mich beenden ich muss nicht 120 sekunden warten
ich denke es hat man soweit verstanden also unsere pakete werden selbstverständlich getroppt also habe ich nachgeguckt
was ist was ist los was macht das da unter der haube
und ich kann ich kann euch das ganze auch mal zeigen wenn wenn ihr kann ich nicht habe ich das gte plugin ich glaube ich
habe nicht das gte plugin
ne ich habe nicht das gte plugin also
ich versuche das jetzt mal in zwei drei sätzen zusammenfasst zusammenzufassen was jetzt eigentlich wirklich passiert ist also wenn du cube ctl startest
das erste was geladen wird ist ein google
authentifizierung plugin
warum werden die pakete nur alle 15 minuten getroppt die werden immer getroppt das wirst du aber gleich bei der erklärung verstehen
die werden immer getroppt aber die werden nicht immer geschickt
also das erste was passiert wenn du cube ctl aufrufst bei mir also wenn ich hier wenn ich zum beispiel sowas sage
cube ctl get
pods minus a
gut ich habe jetzt kein kombiniertes cluster bei mir laufen so sah das aus bei mir auf der arbeit genau so
das hing jetzt für 120 sekunden allerdings aus einem anderen grund wie bei mir lokal
und ging nicht weiter und könnt ihr ihr könnt euch vorstellen es war abfuck extrem
also es funktioniert folgendermaßen cube ctl wird aufgerufen
dann wird ein authentifizierung ein google authentifizierung plugin geladen
ace ace da danke für den prime sub
Nice da wird ein google authentifizierung plugin geladen weil wir halt sachen der google cloud verwenden und das credentials checken muss
dieses google
Authentifizierung plugin greift auf das g cloud
auf das g cloud komando zeilen tool zu
was unter der haube ungefähr sowas hier ausführt
konfig helper
Jason bla bla bla bla keine ahnung und dieser g cloud befehl der wiederum
macht ein request
an eine public ip und beziehungsweise einen public domain
unterhalb von g static.com g static ist eine seite von google wo plateien oftmals drüber ausgeliefert werden
und erlädt sich dann von g static.com eine
Product feature punkt xml oder punkt jason runter das dient dazu
dass beispielsweise das ein
versions check machen kann update check ob ob die
commandline tools aktuell sind so und auf dem system wo wir unser cube ctl ausgeführt haben das hatte keine internetverbindung
das heißt das ding hat versucht
alle 15 minuten
Eine
Meinst du im public domain zappt ja ja ich meine öffentliche webseite halt dahinter
also
subdomain
von der öffentlich erreichbaren seite also im prinzip hat er sich versucht zu verbinden auf www.g
g static.com
twitch twitch
so und
Daraufhin hing das halt und das ding war halt war halt das
Dieses tool hat die ergebnisse einfach 15 minuten gecached und dann hat es wieder probiert also eigentlich ist die erklärung ganz einfach
das tool hat auch wenn es über drei umwege ging versucht ins internet zuzugreifen die pakete ins internet wurden getroppt
und dementsprechend hing das tool bis zum curl timeout das ist alles
Aber da muss man halt erst mal darauf kommen
Ist für ist ist twitch kaputt wirklich
Schauen wir doch das liegt bestimmt an twitter
Oder bin ich gebannt
Nee okay es scheint wieder zu gehen
liegt leute die e-mail adresse ist nicht liegt das ist eine fake e-mail adresse die ich angelegt habe nur
um hier in dem chat was zu schreiben
Die die benutze ich normalerweise gar nicht
das ist weder die e-mail adresse vom von meinem account noch sonst was
dass die das dient einzig und allein dazu
ja
Und ich benutze die auch für nix
first time chatter kam kam bei mir gerade
Ja okay also noch mal ganz kurz zurück zu dem thema ich glaube man hat es verstanden woran es lag oder
Also die ganze cube ctl geschichte ich glaube es hat man verstanden woran es gelegen hat so und das witzige ist google wusste
google war das selbst gar nicht so ganz klar
Bis wir einen ticket bei google aufgemacht haben beziehungsweise gab es ein ticket
Aber das war das war auch so eine geile sagen zu diesem fehler hatten wir einen ticket bei red hat und ein ticket bei google
Und google hat gesagt das muss an unserer das muss an unserer red hat betriebssystem version liegen
Und red hat hat gesagt das muss an google liegen
also der übliche enterprise business wahnsinn also und als als wir meine erkenntnisse dann in das google ticket geschrieben haben
hat google quasi in ihrer antwort das ganze noch mal wiederholt und bestätigt und uns erklärt
Ja wurden nach zwei minuten timeout ging das dann
Und haben uns erklärt dass es ein paar ja so halb offizielle
Commandline flex und environment variablen gibt wenn man die angibt dann wird dieser versions updates diese update check
nicht durchgeführt
Aber du hast ja die commandos wie gesagt die commandos wurden alle ausgeführt
Danke für deinen dort falls man arktik sieht nun gut aus du just achte acht acht ticks ja aber das ist auch ein archlinux oder
by the way
einfach einfach superior
distribution
bestes bestes linux wobei wir uns ja alle einig sind leute dass das ja eigentlich linux ist sondern knu
slash linux oder wie es manche nennen knu plus linux
Lass mich raten dieses thema
Ehrlich gesagt keine ahnung wo man die offiziell findet vielleicht stehen die auch in der hilfeseite
Irgendwo bei google also wir haben nichts gefunden und ich möchte ich müsste mal nach dem suchen was uns google da geschickt hat aber
Es funktioniert auf jeden fall
Please allow me to interject for a moment genau
hat mich
Wundert mich dass keiner die copypasta hier gespamt hat also hat es nach einem update wieder funktioniert mit einem update hat das nichts zu tun
Du musst bevor du das ausführst
Musst du die passende environment variable option setzen oder die passende option mitgeben für
Die für die ist für das command line tool und nachdem das command line tool
Gcloud das gcloud ziel eine über drei ecken aufruft hilft im endeffekt nur setzen der environment variable
Twitch twitch kackt gerade richtig ab habe ich gelesen schon öfters ja
Ein kanal hat ein millionen ich hätte nichts dagegen wenn ich das bin
Lass uns mal kurz gucken wie kaputt das ganze ist
Oh
Ziemlich ziemlich brauchen ziemlich brauchen
Status twitch
Service negatively impacted könnte man so sagen ja
Sie investigaten das issue das haben sie aber schon vor zwei
Nee
Eine halbe stunde oder so geschrieben
Die war noch mal utc sind zwei stunden das haben sie vor eineinhalb stunden geschrieben
Ich kann mir das ich kann mir das immer nicht merken nur
Ja das haben sie vor eineinhalb stunden geschrieben
Ja wie gesagt bei mir so siehst bei mir geht es nicht wenn ich jetzt ein paar mal refreshen dann geht es wahrscheinlich wieder
nicht januar
Also
Jetzt war mein channel auch mal wieder kurz kaputt 3,2 millionen das
glaube ich ehrlich gesagt
Nichts was ist das
Wow
alter die spanier
Aber aber ich 3,2 millionen glaube ich doch nicht das erscheint mir dann doch sehr viel mein absolute
Absolute top streamer hier auf twitch haben irgendwie teilweise da irgendwie 60k zuschauer und sowas
Der hat schon oft so gut dann ist es irgendein spezial event ich kenne nicht weil ich kenne mich in der spanischen twitch
Szene nicht so aus okay twitch ist kaputt
zumindest zumindest teilweise ist twitch kaputt
Tja was machen wir da jetzt chat wir machen einfach weiter oder ich meine wir können nichts daran ändern dass twitch kaputt ist
Er kriege ich meine was sollen wir machen es ist halt kaputt kann es sein dass das stream twitch killt
Es wäre merkwürdig ehrlich gesagt
Wenn ein einzelner stream twitch kaputt machen kann
Das ist doch alles das ist doch alles hyper scalte cloud infrastruktur aber ich meine
Sicherlich sicherlich möglich es gibt bestimmt die ein oder anderen
engpässe
Weiß man nicht
Bin mal gespannt bin mal bin mal gespannt was was für analysen falls irgendwelche analysen gibt
Wir normalerweise würde ich jetzt ja sagen wir gehen auf twitter
Und gucken uns an was twitch so schreibt das problem ist nur wir können twitter ja nicht mehr aufmachen
Also insofern
30 mal im aus
Okay, weil du es bist ich habe ich habe es geändert
Ich würde sagen das sollen die uns mal als
Consultants hinzuziehen wie das richtig funktioniert
Aber die benutzen ja nicht google cloud die benutzen abs datei maute das ja höchstwahrscheinlich gar nicht
Habe ich sonst noch irgendwas verpasst heute ach ja was ich auch im internet gelesen haben wir haben wir haben eindeutig zu viele keg immer was mittlerweile
Ja vor fünf minuten habe ich das erklärt für 15 minuten
Was ich heute auch gelesen habe ist der entwickler von herr der ringe gollum
Hat gesagt sie wollen in zukunft sie wollen in zukunft keine spiele mehr machen
War wohl nicht so ein großer erfolg wie sie sich das erhofft haben aber ganz im ernst das spiel
Das spiel war auch abfuck na besser ist würde ich gar nicht sagen die haben paar ganz gute adventure games gemacht wenn man auch so was
steht
Aber das war halt schon fail ich meine das war so ein typisches game wo du dir vom allerersten trailer an gedacht hast was das für
Ein kack vor allem
Wisst ihr was ich was ich an diesem game überhaupt nicht verstanden habe wie die allen ernsthaft auf die idee gekommen sind moment was das
Für immer und das hat habe ich ja noch nie gesehen
Das ist ja mega nice das benutzt nur nie jemand
Chat warum benutzt ihr das nicht das passt richtig gut hier auf den stellen eigentlich
Das haben wir noch nicht so lange oder das haben wir noch nicht so lang
Das ist auch ein richtiger high-res-keg w guck mal da ist der ist viel besser aufgelöst wie die anderen
Das hat mich abgelenkt jetzt habe ich was wollte ich sagen gerade
Jetzt habe ich vergessen chat wovon habe ich gerade angefangen ach so ja ich weiß wieder ich weiß wieder ich weiß ja
Ich weiß auch gar nicht wie die auf die idee kommen gekommen sind dass irgendjemand golum spielen will hat wirklich irgendjemand herr der ringe geguckt
oder gelesen
Oder die hobbit filme geguckt oder was auch immer und sich gedacht
Ich also golum ist so ein charakter den ich mal gerne im game spielen würde im leben nicht
Niemand niemand wollte golum spielen oder hörbuch ja ich muss sagen ich habe herr der ringe auch nie gelesen
Ich habe nur die filme geguckt und tatsächlich in den 12 13 stunden hörbuch oder so mir angehört
Noch länger das ging ewig
Das ist schon paar paar jahre her also paar jahre ist gut bestimmt ist bestimmt 15 jahre her so
Das war kein hörbuch das war ein hörspiel
Es ging aber auch irgendwie 13 12 13 14 stunden oder so aber das war halt das war halt so ein bisschen
mit acting dabei und so
Das war gar nicht übel das habe ich auf jeden fall gehört bevor ich die filme gesehen habe dass ich bescheid wusste
Naja
Das habe ich auf jeden fall gehört bevor ich die filme gesehen habe dass ich bescheid wusste
naja
das ordentlich viel
Ich höre mir im hintergrund immer irgendwelche sinnlosen youtube videos an
also wirklich sinnlose sinnlose youtube videos so
World of warcraft lore videos und so was da kann man gut bei bei penn
Mich ich bin kein wow spieler mich interessiert die world of warcraft lore überhaupt nicht aber da kann man richtig gut bei penn
Ist das nicht so dass sie die game of thrones bücher bei uns jedes buch in in zwei gesplittet haben in deutschland so ganz merkwürdig
dass bei uns irgendwie acht oder so gibt
das problem ist ist dabei dass bei gollum die story also man kennt den charakter halt
und das ist halt da ist halt nichts was sich interessiert die hätten irgendein irgendein
Unbekannten hobbit nehmen müssen oder so hätte es vielleicht noch geklappt
ach keine ahnung
Das ist auch so ein game wo ich mir dachte das vom ersten trailer an das ist müll
aber das ist auf englisch und wenn ich eins gelernt habe ist von englisch
ein
englischsprachigen serien oder
Serien den originalton wenn ich da eins gelernt habe ist dass es manche englischen dialekte gibt wo ich nichts verstehe
das kommt schon daher dass dass die nicht sagen fuck sondern es gibt manche engländer oder manche manche dialekte dort die sagen
Das kann man gerade nachmachen die machen die sagen sowas wie
rocken rocken
Das hört übelst mir an für leute die sie also ich verstehe die auch nicht also es gibt einige dialekte die die kannst du nicht
verstehen
Max was hältst du von jobhopping alle eins bis drei jahre ich persönlich nix ich finde es eigentlich ganz nice irgendwo zu sein
Wo man weiß wie die sache läuft ja wo ein die leute kennen wo man die leute kennt wo man irgendwie weiß auf was man sich
so einlässt
natürlich
Im besten fall wenn das dann auch was ist wo es einem gefällt
Wenn es wenn ich einfach nichts finden würde mal angenommen ich stelle jetzt in einem dreivierteljahr fest
Das ist richtig mies am besten wäre es wird es noch in der probezeit feststellen aber aktuell ist es
Aktuell gefällt es mir ja deswegen aber ich stelle mir vor ich würde in dem jahr feststellen boah das ist ja richtig mies da habe ich
Hätte ich so gar nicht daran gedacht ja dann vielleicht schon aber ansonsten ich bin ja niemand der sich oft was neues sucht ich meine
Wann jobhopping zu uns
Wenn es ja irgendwas gibt
dann musste mir aber dann musste mich aber
Mit anteilen bezahlen dass ich dann auch millionär werde weil wie war das in fünf in fünf jahren willst du nicht mehr arbeiten
dann muss da muss schon irgendwie sich dann auch
perspektivisch lohnen
Das habe ich nicht auf englisch geguckt
Also ich wie gesagt um das abzulehnen ich nix ich nix max was denkst du
Wäre ein gutes einstiegsgehalt als bäcker entwickler in frankfurt an einem bachelor studium
Finanzbranche oder nicht finanzbranche ist die große frage in frankfurt wahrscheinlich finanzbranche oder
Frankfurt ist ja in jeder ecke wo du hinguckst oder hinspruchs ist ja irgendwas in der richtung
Und dann auch massig it dienstleister und sowas ja schwer zu sagen
Also
Bei entwickler gehälter und bei einstieg ist das liegt halt daran da habe ich keine persönliche erfahrung ich arbeite hauptberuflich als entwickler und ich
habe auch nicht wirtschaft sind von
Du hast gar nicht geschrieben was ich habe auch nicht studiert
Also ich kann das schlecht sagen also ich kann nicht sagen dass ich damals nach meiner ausbildung
33.500 euro gekriegt habe als aller allererstes einstiegsgehalt das heißt das ist das absolute
Komplette also wenn man das mal wie viel ist das heute mit inflationen sachen dabei
14 40k oder so also das sollte das absolute minimum frankfurt und finanzbranche sein in der heutigen zeit
Also würde ich also würde ich sagen als einstiegsgehalt kann dann durchaus noch mal ein bisschen was drauf kommen
Also ich denke mal unter 45k solltest du es auf gar keinen fall machen da findest du wahrscheinlich andere die mehr bezahlen
Aber ich sag mal 45k aufwärts
Sollte es sollte es schon sein aber es hängt natürlich ein bisschen davon ab also welche branche genau
Was du kannst natürlich auch weil ich meine du kannst zwar bachelor studium haben aber du kannst trotzdem sacken als back-end entwickler weiß ich
Ja nicht also glaube ich nicht weil sonst würdest du den stream nicht angucken im stream wissen wir ja sind ja prinzipiell alle high-IQ
Inflationsgehalt okay zeigt man ja rechnen wir jetzt mal aus
also bruttogehalt
36.500 datum der letzten gehalts
Was jetzt los
Wann war das
okay
also
lese ich das richtig dass das jetzt
46.000 sein sollten man muss es ja dann rückwärts lesen in dem in dem sinn ja
Also da bin ich doch mit meinen 45k gar nicht so schlecht als exakter zahl
Ich sehe hier nichts ja aber gut dann also wie gesagt
45 ist da schon also da drunter würde ich es nicht machen
Aber wie gesagt du musst du musst dann auch ein bisschen was auf die reihe kriegen aber du hast auf jeden fall gute
Entwicklungsmöglichkeiten in der frankfurter finanzbranche als itler ist es jetzt mal egal ob es
admin er admin geschichten sind oder eher
programmier software entwicklungsgeschichten du hast auf jeden fall gute möglichkeiten in den nächsten jahren dein gehalt zu verdoppeln
Wenn du was auf die reihe kriegst
Ja bin ich auch
Ich überlege gerade den job zu wechseln nach 18 jahren und ohne lust bewerbung zu schreiben ja gut wahrscheinlich ist dein alter job geht dir so
auf den sack
Das problem ist wenn man 18 jahre bei bei was dabei gewesen ist das kann ich euch aus eigener erfahrung berichten ja
Wenn man lange zeit irgendwo dabei gewesen ist da gehen einem neue sachen auch
verhältnismäßig viel auf den sack
Also gerade wenn man weiß dass manche sachen vielleicht gefühlt früher besser gelaufen sind gehen dann neue entscheidungen oftmals besonders auf den sack
Gar nicht mal weil die neuen entscheidung unbedingt prinzipiell schlecht sein müssen
Ja das habe ich auch bei bei manchen sachen bei mir beim alten arbeitgeber gemerkt dass ich mir gedacht habe
Das hatte die doch schon mal ein besser ja warum jetzt sowas komisches aber ich gehe mal davon aus wenn du jetzt überlegt du bist
Wahrscheinlich so ein bisschen drauf wie ich in der richtung lese ich da jetzt zumindest raus du hast eigentlich keinen bock
Dir was zu suchen du hast keinen bock bewerbung zu schreiben und sowas in der richtung
Aber es geht ja auf der anderen seite so sehr auf den sack bei deinem aktuellen job dass du doch dran dann drüber nachdenkst
Also ich kann ja eigentlich nur raten
Also neben bewerbung schreiben wobei man ehrlich gesagt sagen muss ich habe gar keine bewerbung geschrieben für meinen jetzigen job
die zwei die zwei
Verträge also wo ich dann einen davon unterschrieben habe habe ich tatsächlich über
Umwege bekommen von leuten die also da bin ich hingekommen über leute die ich schon kannte von früher also auch da wo ich jetzt arbeite
Und es gibt allerdings ja mehr möglichkeiten heute zu gucken ja also ist auf jeden fall sinnvoll
Ein aktuelles github profil zu haben wenn es um entwicklungssachen geht aber auch als admin auch als der forbes mensch
aktuelles github profil ist nie verkehrt
und
Im link in profil wenn man da bock drauf hat ist ja nicht auch nicht verkehrt
Da kriegst du zwar auch viel müll aber vielleicht sind die ein oder anderen sinnvollen anfragen dabei
Du bist auf jeden fall schon mal nicht nicht mehr ganz neu in dem gebiet wenn du seit 18 jahren am start bist
Also ich kann dir nur empfehlen wie gesagt unabhängig von bewerbung schreiben und sonst was es macht sinn sich woanders zu bewerben
allein schon
Für die erfahrung die du sammeln kannst was vorstellungsgespräche und und bewerbungssachen und so angeht denn wenn dann wirklich mal es irgendwie hart auf hart
Kommt dass du sagst alle ich halte es da jetzt gar nicht mehr auf dann hast du wenigstens einen aktuellen lebenslauf und hast auch schon ein
bisschen geübt und wenn es dann darauf ankommt kannst du immer noch sagen gut jetzt bewerbe ich mich woanders
auf der anderen seite
hast du jetzt die beste position
Du kannst dich bewerben beziehungsweise du kannst dich werben lassen wie auch immer du kannst dahin gehen du kannst
Ein bisschen erfahrung sammeln du kannst auch relativ sicher sagen was du haben willst du kannst auch dahin gehen und sagen hier ich will
das und das selbst wenn es dir ein bisschen unverschämt vorkommt ja bei
Bei gehaltsforderungen sagt man immer so das erste was man sagt sollte immer so
Ganz
an der grenze zu unverschämt sein also an der grenze was hier unverschämt vorkommt dass man sich dann eben ein bisschen drunter einigen kann
aber zumindest
Hast du eine super position weil du musst das neue ja nicht annehmen du bist ja auch in der guten verhandlungsposition
Wenn du einen guten job hast oder wo du dir zumindest im vorfeld denkst das ist was schönes was dir gefallen könnte und ihr seid
euch da auch soweit einig aber die kohle stimmt halt nicht mit deinen vorstellungen überein kannst du immer noch sagen also
ich mir hat es ja richtig gut gefallen
Aber ich glaube das ist einfach nicht
Entspricht einfach nicht meinen vorstellungen und dann legen sie ja vielleicht noch was drauf
Also wenn die viele legen noch was drauf wenn die merken du gehst jetzt gleich raus und das war es dann
also
Du hast jetzt eine gute position wenn du schon einen job hast
Du hast eine stellenanzeige vom zdf gefunden ok monkaS
Gucken wir uns gleich an
Wie ist das eigentlich auf deiner neuen arbeit bist du auf der arbeit immer noch eingeschränkt ja ich habe ein super restriktives notebook aber ich
habe glücklicherweise linux vor allem auf der ich gut bin
nicht finanzbranche trotzdem 45k finde ich
Immer noch ganz gut als einstieg
damit was haben sie da was haben sie dann angeboten
oder hast du ihnen ein angebot oder
Oder willst du wissen was du sagen kannst weil wenn du wissen willst was du sagen kannst dann würde ich nicht 45k sagen
45k ist das wo ich so drunter nicht anfangen würde in der heutigen zeit
auch als einsteiger aber
Sagen würde ich würde ich eine ganze ecke mehr
So dass das jetzt fast schon unverschämt vorkommt dass es dann am ende nicht nicht weniger ist weil wenn du am anfang direkt sagst
45k hast du zwei möglichkeiten entweder sagen die ja wohl die sind eingestellt dann weißt du okay es hätte noch so wäre noch deutlich mehr gegangen
Oder sie handeln nicht sogar da noch ein bisschen runter
Weil sie merken da geht was
Sagt lieber gleich 75k wie der chanel vorschlägt
Dann ist am ende halt das werden die nicht bezahlen wahrscheinlich für ein als einstiegsgehalt
Aber dann können sie immer noch sagen okay
Irgendwie traut sich in deutschland keine firma über 100k hinaus zu gehen also bei mir schon
Im max hast du etwas an deinen twitch stream einstellung verändert ich bekomme nur bei dir in den overlay der sagt nee twitch ist gerade kaputt
twitch twitch ist broken
Aber kein ton oh ja
Dann wird das jetzt wahrscheinlich nicht gehört haben einfach die seite so oft wie es geht refreshen
Deswegen habe ich auch gesagt unten drunter würde ich es nicht machen ich bin mitte 20 und mir geht laut auf den sack
okay
warum
Was würdest du sagen sollte nach zwei jahren
Mindestens drin sein als developer das kann man echt schwer sagen ich meine wie gesagt
Region branche was man was man genau macht
Also ich kann dir zumindest als einstiegsgehalt unter 45k würde ich heute nicht anfangen zum einstieg
Also da kannst du da noch ein bisschen was draufhauen man mit zwei jahren bist ja nicht mehr komplett grün in den ohren
Da weißt du ja auch schon deutlich besser bescheid wie es in der büsten des enterprise welt so läuft
Da kann schon mal eine ecke mehr sein
Ja
Du kannst das theoretisch schon zum größten teil selbst bauen willst du bloß halt nicht
Wobei es jetzt also solche solche sachen gibt wie vor allem wer
Tänzu oder tanzu oder wie das heißt die quasi so eine kubernetes api
Auf einem erst x-server oder irgendwas in der richtung bauen das ist dann quasi
Virtualisiert und drunter du musst dich um die scaling sachen nicht mal kümmern habe ich nur letztens mal eine präsentation
Zugesehen kein schlimmer wie das wirklich funktioniert ob das taugt
Ja komplett komplett
Augen zu und durch cloud macht ja auch also hat ja noch nie sinn gemacht man muss immer gucken was von der architektur ist
Was von der architektur sinnvoll ist für das was man halt machen will
Was gleich an
Go rust java typescript
Ach so stehen da zu gucken wir uns gleich an
Arbeite demnächst im it consulting weiß jemand was genau unter kunden
Verrechenbare stunden gemeint ist und wie ich und wie viel ich dem in rechnung stellen darf naja
Da wird dir die deine consulting firma schon ein crash crash kurs geben wie du ordentlich abrechnung machst
ansonsten wenn ich ist eine scheiße consulting firma
Soldat für administration
Du bist du bist du am studieren das war quasi so eine prophylaktische frage ja
Das sind jetzt aber total unzusammenhängende dinger oder
Der punkt an cloud sind micro services das liegt die die anwendungsarchitektur liegt ganz in der hand dessen der sie sich ausdenkt
Docker images und docker images haben nichts mit skalieren oder cloud prinzipiell zu tun
Autoskalieren muss da auch nix es macht an manchen stellen sind an manchen nicht und dass da irgendwas von nicht performant genug ist kannst du
Prinzipiell auch nicht sagen muss mal gucken wie viele
richtig richtig
Big player technologien in der richtung in der richtung verwenden und das da ganz gut funktioniert also das ist jetzt ein satz der ergibt ehrlich
gesagt ich will ich jetzt nicht bashen so für
Weil ich der ultra cloud fan bin oder so nee es gibt auch viele sachen die ich nicht in der cloud laufen lassen würde aber das
Der zusammenhang ergibt jetzt nicht wirklich so richtig sinn
Aus meiner sicht ja die sache ist die zwischen sagen und bekommen
Bekommen wirst du wahrscheinlich zum einstieg je nachdem wo du bist das auch da nicht
Aber vielleicht einigst du dich am ende dann bei sowas hier und wenn du gleich mit 60 anfängst dann vielleicht aber 45
Danke für dein video heute wir haben auf der arbeit auch das problem das sporadische db verbindung unterbrochen werden niemand hat eine idee wie das problem finden
Ja das wird das wird allerdings mit dem problem von mir nichts zu tun haben
Ich habe gerade am anfang des streams erklärt was es war das hat also gar nichts mit in dieser richtung
sporadische db verbindung unterbrochen
Das kann ja alles sein
Im zweifelsfall immer aufs netzwerkteam schieben die freuen sich ich wollte ich wollte auf irgendwas hier noch eingehen aber ich habe es
bin das nicht mehr also noch könnt ab und zu ja
Generelle frage hat mit komisch welches gehalt fängt er als physik an ich habe es gerade gesagt also mein einstiegsgehalt damals
2007 rum war 23.500 das heißt das sind heute ungefähr 45k
Mit inflation dabei also das sollte schon sein klar schick ja
Was seine channel wieder angestellt
Klickt er jetzt nicht drauf
Max was würdest du an meiner stelle verlangen ach der umhut auch mal wieder am start
Schön dass du hier bist
Was würdest du an meiner stelle verlangen bin der forbes im asia bereich und vollzertifizierter 40 gate network analyst ich habe absolut keine ahnung
was
wie schwer und wie gut und wie
kein schlimmer davon
Aber der forbes im asia bereich ist sicherlich ziemlich gesucht zurzeit
Und wenn ich das richtig im kopf habe du machst es ja auch schon eine weile
Kommt jetzt natürlich wieder sehr auf branche und region an ich glaube du machst es ja auch schon sieben acht jahre lang
also der forbes im asia bereich und und vielleicht netzwerk ich sag mal inklusive
Netzwerk security ahnung ich kann das weiß nicht was dahinter steckt also gehen wir mal von der frankfurter finanzbranche aus da während
Also wenn du das sieben acht jahre machst und eine senior stelle kriegst sind da durchaus 90k plus drinne
Wenn halt auch was auf die reihe kriegst du kriegst du kriegst zurzeit netto netto 90k
bist du in der schweiz oder wie wenn du netto 90k kriegst dann verdienst du ja
170 180 k
Das ist schon ganz ordentlich
Bei so einem gehalt brauchst du sicherlich nicht meinen senf im stream dazu da weißt du doch schon eher was sache ist oder
183 k
It's money it's life
Kommst du aus der schweiz oder ist das hier was war denn der grund für cube ctl
Okay
also ein paar sätze dazu
Ich versuche das mal in einer minute zu erklären also
Cube ctl ruft ein plugin auf um sich gegen google zu authentifizieren das plugin was ich gegen google authentifizieren will ruft die google die gcloud
Cli auf die gcloud cli möchte auf einem public internet seite von google gehen um nachzugucken ob es updates für die tools gibt
Auf dem server wo das ausgeführt wird gibt es allerdings kein internet access und die packages ins internet werden getroppt anstatt zu
rejected das heißt das tool hängt für zwei minuten weil es unter der haube curl verwendet und curl ein default timeout von zwei minuten hat
und cached ist allerdings die ergebnisse das heißt diese zwei minuten timeouts treten alle 15 minuten auf und so aus den cube ctl was alles was
alle 15 minuten für zwei minuten hängt
so das war das problem die cube ctl
Aber du bist ja frei feld google mitarbeiter das war jetzt bestimmt kein problem dass der sache zu folgen
Danke alles verstanden war sogar unter einer minute das ist chat ist einfach zu high iq
machst du mit kubernetes
Also wo wir gerade bei google sind also der der eigentliche fehler lag ja im gcloud cli
Allerdings hat uns google dann so ein paar halb offizielle environment variablen gegeben die man setzen kann dass es diese update abfrage nicht mehr gibt
Das war schon eingebaut das wusste halt keiner
Was war das habe ich doch gerade habe ich doch gerade erklärt genau
Ja das trifft das trifft eigentlich ganz gut ja wobei das tool hat nur die curl
Library zum downloaden unter der haube verwendet
Selbst sind das andere tools noch das wird ja heute richtig richtig hier
penis vergleich alles
Mit was für einem gehalt
Seid ihr als da kann ich nichts zu sagen
trifft mich ja nicht hat mich nicht betroffen
Beim umut bin ich mir immer nicht so ganz sicher ob er nicht ein bisschen rein troll zwischendurch
Weil weil er hat auch schon ein paar comments ich kann mich noch daran erinnern der vergangenheit hat schon ein paar comments geschrieben wo man eigentlich
Offensichtlich ist die welt erkannt hat und ob der jetzt ob der jetzt nicht wieder gbd weiß man halt nicht
Wenn berater und cto bei einer firma ja nice hast du alles richtig gemacht im endeffekt wobei ich mir vorstellen könnte
Dass der job auch echt stressig ist letztendlich
Der meine muss sich um jeden mist kümmern eigentlich hätte ich keinen bock drauf ist es es ist auch der grund warum ich absolut keine
karriere
karriere ambitionen hab
also
Also in der alten arbeit war es halt so
Mein chef hat also auf der alten arbeit mein damaliger chef ja
Der hat halt immer die die die karrieremöglichkeiten
Erzählt so was man so geiles bei uns machen kann und sowas
Und ich habe halt immer gesagt wo habe ich keinen bock drauf aber der hat halt einfach nicht aufgegeben aber irgendwann zu dem zeitpunkt
Wo ich dann gesagt habe ich will lieber teilzeit arbeiten dann hat da haben sie es da ab da haben sie es dann glaube ich glaube ich kapiert
Dass es dass ich echt keine absichten habe was das angeht
Was am ende der zwölften klasse haben wir nun mit dem stoff der 13 klasse begonnen achtschäler du bist noch in der schule
Der sich hauptsächlich mit exis und datenbanken beschäftigt leider bereiten wir das überhaupt keinen spaß
Sind die datenbanken sehr wichtig nee exis braucht kein mensch exis ist outdated overrated
richtiger suma der chanel auch anscheinend
Ich glaube ich glaube chanel
Ich weiß nicht ob es dafür den guinness buch der rekorde eintrag gibt ich glaube chanel ist der jüngste mit den meisten banns im discord
Und wahrscheinlich den meisten neuen accounts
Also datenbanken sind natürlich bei chanel weißt du eh nie ob das jetzt die debate getrolle ist oder
Ernstgemeinte fragen ja aber wir treten das als ernstgemeinte fragen natürlich sind datenbanken wichtig
Aber exis sagt und das wird mir auch keinen bock machen
Was sagst du zu battle bit da habe ich am anfang ja schon was gesagt
Ich habe die ganzen playtests also die meisten nicht alle ich habe die meisten playtests gespielt
Ich habe jetzt auch die exis version gekauft und es gibt halt einen punkt war battle bit der mir persönlich nicht gefällt und ich
Habe nichts gegen pixel grafik ja
Ich ich bin mit super nintendo spielen auf was ich mag pixel grafik
Aber ich finde die grafik nicht gut die ist auch die maps sind viel zu detail arm
Und das liegt nicht so sehr an der grafik sondern einfach weil die maps detail arm sind da hast du
zig häuser die unlogisch miteinander verbunden sind wo nichts drin rumsteht
Nicht mal da steht weniger rum wie noch zu bc1 zeiten wo man wenigstens in den stuhl in einem haus stand oder so gar nichts
Also ich finde ich finde das tatsächlich grafisch sagt es mir nicht zu
Der trick ist dass man beratung für open source macht dort liegt die kohle
ich glaube
Das liegt auch mit daran weil es nicht so viele gibt oder die das machen weil
Für irgendwelche microsoft services findest du doch an jeder ecke irgendeine bude die das macht aber wenn jetzt jemand sagt hey wir bräuchten mal hilfe bei
Tja was ist denn so was ist so ein typisches
Was ist so ein typisches beratungsthema also ein typisches
Produkt open source produkt wo man gerne beratung würde meine fällt klar kubernetes fällt mir ein wobei ich denke da holt man sich weniger beratung
Also geht halt in irgendeine cloud
Der vm champ ja
exis
Können sie nur nicht können sie trailer fragen demnächst
Kafka das ist ein schönes beispiel das könnte ich mir vorstellen
Alle denken sie sich wir machen eine kafka message kürz wird alles besser und dann hat man so keine sau versteht
Ich auch nicht du musst eine neue access anwendung bauen um ein beileid dazu kann ich kann ich sagen keck windows
Ist das nicht so was wie mqtt
Man könnte es vielleicht mit sehr viel guten willen wenn man so eine überkategorie für diese dienste
Definieren müsste in die gleiche kategorie packen in die kategorie message bus message queue
Allerdings kannst du mit kaffka viel mehr machen und von der leichtgewichtigkeit her nicht mit mqtt zu vergleichen
Es ist glaube ich ziemlich kompliziert ist der message infrastruktur die es aktuell so gibt also insofern
Okay dann kommen wir uns noch mal die stellen anzeigen die stellen anzeige bei der chat was wir uns angucken zuerst das zdf oder dann
dann den kubernetes soldat
Mit was man anfangen ach ja irgendjemand wollte mir noch eine stellenanzeige für für seine azubi geschichten schicken oder
Kannst du kannst du ruhig machen wer auch immer das war
Der df ok
Also was will das zdf haben ich hoffe ich habe hier einen dark modus wenn ich das hier aufmache
War
monkaS
Okay, also was was sucht denn das zdf erst mal richtig richtig viel wall of wall of text
Für unseren standort in mainz suchen wir zum das ist das ist die
Haupt der hauptstandort vom zdf oder weil die hat noch die meinzelmännchen früher und das heißt doch bestimmt nicht ohne grund so
für unseren
Für unseren standort
Bechtle okay aber gleich danach ich wollte heute eigentlich kein wir gucken und stellen anzeigen stream machen aber warum nicht
Okay
Also sie suchen ein software develop was software development
Sie suchen einen software developer sie suchen nicht software development software development kann nicht männlich weiß deutsch sein
Du suchst dir auch einen software entwickler und nicht software entwicklung
Ja gut was soll ich jetzt
Wir wollen jetzt mal nicht
Päpstlicher sein als der parms okay wir wissen was sie meinen
Achso unterstützung für unser team software die wird okay ihr habt recht das habe ich nicht gelesen
Was aber auch schon hinweis darauf ist dass die stellenanzeige irgendwie sagt okay
Also lasst mal gucken was wollen die haben
Deine aufgaben du analysierst konzipiert und implementierst deine
Konzipierst und implementierst als software entwickler gemeinsam mit deinem team und
was
gemeinsam mit deinem team und in einem agilen agile
In einem agilen umfeld software lösung ja gut das macht man als anwendungsentwickler oder
Programmierer halt so dass man software entwickelt okay
Du bist teil eines krumm teams und verantwortlich sind super agil ich frage mich auch ob die
T-shape team strukturen und kann man boards und und auch alle nach safe arbeiten und sowas
Und ich hoffe die skalieren auch schön horizontal vertikal und diagonal
Und die sprints sind auch in regelmäßigen abständen
Sprint planung
Du bist teil eines krumm teams und verantwortet gemeinsam im team die konzeption
Umsetzung und den betrieb unserer lösung und produkte das ist wieder so 0 8 15 bewerbungs bullshit satz
Weil das keinen sinn ergibt ihr sucht ein software entwickler
Ihr sucht niemand der dann im endeffekt eine cloud infrastruktur aufbaut wo die anwendung drauf läuft
Ihr sucht jemand der das entwickelt der das da das vielleicht auch
Testet an der architektur mitarbeitet das umsetzt aber für den betrieb nicht das ist wieder so das ist wieder so 0 15 satz
Der eigentlich falsch ist der da steht weil in den seltenen fällen suchen die entwickler die den kram im endeffekt dann
Irgendwo aufbauen und selbst betreiben
Oder die suchen wirklich keinen software entwickler nennen es nur so ja du schreibst nicht nur code sondern unterstützt deine kolleginnen und deine
KollegInnen ich dachte da muss man das i großschreiben an der stelle
Auch mit code reviews konfiguriert ce und delivery pipelines und kümmert sich um das deployment der anwendung in die cloud
Okay
Ja das ist so ein bisschen der forbes umfeld allerdings wenn man sich mal so die reine die reine lehre hinter der forbes anguckt
Dann sind es ja nicht irgendwelche admins den es einfach zu oldschool ist an sich admins zu nennen und jetzt dass ich der forbes engineers nennen
Sondern eigentlich kommt es ja aus der richtung dass entwickler ihren kram nicht nur programmieren sondern ihn dann in zukunft auch betreiben also insofern
Wenn es eher in die in die der forbes
Development
Obstrichtung geht dann ergibt das schon sinn
Du arbeitest gemeinsam wobei man halt klar sein muss dass du dann halt auch nicht alles tiefgreifend machen kannst also ist ja nicht so dass du
dann
Jemanden kaufst der alle bei mehr sachen den überblick hat und den kannst du dann auch in der tiefe in jedem bereich so einsetzen wie
Beispielsweise in spezialisierten java
backen entwickler oder sowas
Egal weiter
Du schreibe du arbeitest gemeinsam mit deinem team an abwechslungsreichen projekten für unser eigenes unternehmen sowie externe kunden
Ja dein profil das bringst du mit
So jetzt bin ich mal gespannt was muss man haben
Du konntest bereits mindestens ein jahr berufserfahrung am software unternehmen sammeln okay
Legitime anforderungen die wollen hat keine noch frisch aus der uni kommt oder aus der ausbildung
Du verfügst aber abgeschlossenes studium oder eine vergleichbare qualifikation im bereich der softwareentwicklung
Wie ist eine ausbildung keine vergleichbare qualifikation weil das ist sie nicht
Das wird immer so geschrieben aber das sind schon grundsätzlich unterschiedliche sachen
Also ich würde nicht sagen dass jemand in der ausbildung gemacht hat theoretisch also was die was die theoretischen hintergründe ist
Angeht auf dem niveau ist von jemand der studiert hatten umgedreht würde ich sagen jemand der studiert hat
Der hat nicht die praxis erfahrung von jemand der drei jahre ausbildung gemacht hat also ich weiß was sie meinen physik ausbildung oder
fachinformatiker anwendungsentwicklung ausbildungs auch vollkommen okay aber man könnte ja schon noch
Ausbildung reinschreiben so jetzt kommt es darauf an was sie haben wollen du bist sicher in mehreren imperativen programmier sprachen
Warum warum exakt müssen die gut klingt klingt einfach cooler an der stelle
Du bist sicher in mehreren imperativen programmier sprachen sowie in front-end und back-end ach das kommt auch noch dabei
Du okay, man, wait a minute du machst front-end back-end
deployments cloud-infrastruktur
Ja, okay, zdf jetzt wollen wir vielleicht und das ganze natürlich super agil jetzt wollen wir mal nicht übertreiben
Okay, so wie front-end back-end technologien beispielsweise
go
rust
java
scripts
Javascript peisens es message queues docker und what the fuck
Okay, ich mein
Es ist nicht ganz weit her dass du jemanden findest der davon ahnung hat
Aber was davon wollen die jetzt wirklich haben
der beispielsweise
Wo ist der sinn was spezifisches aufzuführen wenn man wenn man das eigentlich nicht sucht also
zumal das auch alles ganz unterschiedliches zeug ist
Na gut ist nicht so wild
geht die wollen wahrscheinlich einfach nur sicherstellen dass sich da irgendjemand bewirbt der ein bisschen ahnung hat
Und haben halt ein bisschen best oft reingeschrieben
warum ausgerechnet
ausgerechnet rust
Ich mein rust ist halt
Heißer scheiß aber im business umfeld gar nicht so sehr verbreitet
Interessant na gut gucken wir mal weiter
Muss gerade mal kurz auf dem zweiten bildschirm was checken ok so weiter
Du hast erfahrung in der entwicklung von kontainerisierten anwendung ok ja sinnvoll die sind hier richtig cloud native unterwegs
Du bist geübt im umgang mit versionskontrollen das finde ich gut dass das drin steht es gibt immer noch leute im jahr
2023 in der arbeit und nicht so viel plan von github ist für mich ganz gut da kann ich immer auf den kann ich immer auf
großer github machen
weil ich kenne mich ganz brauchbar aus
Aber es erschreckt mich es erschreckt mich immer ein bisschen
dass es dass es immer noch leute gibt die so gar keinen plan davon haben und sich und sich teilweise sogar schwer tun mit
einfachsten sachen wie so nach dem motto
Ich
Mache mit und push das und es klappt nicht richtig so
Du bist erfahren in der umsetzung von tineus integration continuous deployment pipelines github actions
Jenkins also dass ich schon alles ein bisschen querbeet ich würde sagen die suchen eigentlich weniger
ein software developer die suchen tatsächlich
Eigentlich das was man heute so unter der forbes ingenieur versteht
Weil es geht gar nicht so sehr ums richtig so ums entwickeln das wird jetzt zwar auch mal erwähnt aber es geht auch oftmals ums
betreiben und testen und deployen der anwendung
Hast du dein github schon gehalten ich habe ich habe auch
Mir noch gar nichts großartiges überlegt also ich habe ein paar powerpoint sachen zusammen gebastelt jetzt so als intro
Ich mache es ja auch nicht lang ich werde es nicht erst drei stunden erzählen historie von geht juckt eh kein
Erzählen dass ich das gleiche du ausgedacht hat der sich auch linux überlegt hat dem man übrigens
Linus torvalds ausspricht ich habe mir das letztens mal angeguckt dass sie an finnisch
Finde und man sprichte nicht leines torvalds aus oder linus torvalds sondern
linus torvalds
Linus torvalds spricht bei den aus du verfügst über sehr gute deutschen englischkenntnis in wort und schrift ja
Der fuck you nvidia typ genau
Darauf hast du lust okay jetzt kommt web applikation frontend und backend
medienmanagement und workflow systeme
Okay, wordpress
Wahrscheinlich android und ios ach das auch noch
2d und 3d anwenden what the fuck jetzt wird es aber automatisiertes testen der eigene antenne
Das ist schon äußerst
viel zu viel
Das ist schon äußerst vielfältig weil es ist
Frontend backend web es ist mobile apps
Irgendwelche ja wie auch immer geartete sachen für
video fernsehübertragung und
Was auch immer ne keine ahnung
Testing sonst was
Ich meine ich habe schon schlimmeres gesehen aber was anforderungen angeht was die alles haben wollten ja
Ich meine es steht es steht zumindest nicht drin endanwender support und sowas also geht geht denke ich schon irgendwo klar
Ich könnte mir vorstellen dass das zdf an sich auch kein schlechter arbeitgeber ist weil das zdf hat einen vorteil den geht nie das geld aus
Zumindest auf absehbare zeit
Wir sorgen wir alle mit dafür dass die immer genug kohle haben also wahrscheinlich geht es einem da geht es einem da ganz gut
Okay, was bekommt man denn dafür
Bei uns erwartet die spannende abwechslungsreiche herausforderung bla bla bla bla wir aber nach agilen entwicklung ja bla bla bla gemeinsam mit dem
bla bla bla bla
Sind sehr gut durch öffentliche okay hier warte ich ein heller
Ergonomischer arbeitsplatz mit allen arbeitsmitteln die du brauchst ja das würde ich auch erwarten dass sie mich mit allem ausstattet was ich brauche zum arbeiten
neben erfahren können 30 tage
Außer
Firmenevents alter dass sie immer noch denken dass firmenevents irgendwas geiles sind damit sich aber gut kombiniert das besteht außerdem nach absprache
mit der führungskraft die möglichkeit auf flexible arbeitszeitgestaltung sowie ein hybrides arbeitsmodell mit einem mix aus
mobilen arbeit und anwesenheit im büro das ist ja schon mal ganz gut die frage ist nur wie
flexibel die flexible arbeitszeitgestaltung dennoch ist
Ich meine vielleicht sagen die auch ja ne eigentlich mögen wir homeoffice nicht so ein tag die woche und es war
kontakt
da sich
Was hat es mit dem kontakt zu tun
Moment muss ich mal lehnen da sich unser content an viel eine vielseitige gesellschaft richtet möchten wir auch in unser team die
gesellschaftliche vielfalt repräsentieren ach so das ist wieder das behinderte
Sich bewerben soll und sowas auch wenn du unserem anwenden ach nee doch nicht hä auch wenn du unserem
Anforderungsprofil nicht zu 100 prozent entsprichst ja gut 100 prozent werdet ihr eh keinen für finden
freuen wir uns darauf dich durch deinen lebenslauf kennenzulernen
Außerdem freuen wir uns wenn du uns arbeitsproben githab das finde ich gut dass sie danach fragen
Mitsticks und deine gehaltsvorstellung sowie deinen frühstmöglichen eintrittstermin
Verrätst wirklich jetzt hier in unserem portal
Let's go
Über uns das wir uns nicht lesen ja ich habe eigentlich gedacht nach diesem introsatz kommt jetzt die übliche geschichte
Behinderte sollen sich bewerben frauen sollen sich bewerben so kam aber nichts also
Warum auch immer das dasteht muss einfach zdf internet easy money ja okay dann haben wir noch eine ein haben wir noch eine sache
Soldatinnen soldat für it-administration
Musst du denn da wirklich ich musste da wirklich in der uniform vom monitor sitzen und dir
Nagios oder irgendwas in der richtung
eher visio
Alter seht ihr die leiste da unten das sieht aus wie winos 98 oder xp
Okay, also zeigt mal ja was gibt es hier was haben die denn so am start
Was haben die denn so am start
Also als
IT-administrator
Begleiten sie die entwicklung bla bla bla digitalen streiten sie erkennen digitale bedrohung
Okay hier geht es jetzt im einsatz installieren sie blitzschnell mobile und hochsichere
Im einsatz die meinen aber nicht ich muss irgendwohin und mir den poppers wegschießen lassen oder die meinen
in
Meinem einsatz wird die werden die installiert sie überwachen serverbasierte netze und vorhandene systeme werden von ihnen modernisiert
Da hast du bei der bundeswehr sicherlich viel zu tun
Ihre fachliche zuarbeit im netzbereich unterstützt verschiedene projekte die in diesem zukunftsfeld eröffnen sich ihnen ausgezeichnete qualifizierung
Chancen die breit gefächerte aufgaben palette als it-administrator bietet ihnen eine praktische erfahrung gibt abla bla
die tätigkeit also ihre
Okay das ist jetzt bundeswehr speak ich habe keine ahnung was da der unterschied ist
Es sind drei drei drei sachen in einem irgendwie
Aber muss keine krankenversicherung bezahlen ist das gar nicht so schlecht
Sie konfigurieren ort ortsfeste und mobile warne ladeneinrichtungen
Sie überwachen die nutzung der von ihnen die sie sind ansprechende sie beheben störfälle ja gut
Was für sie zählen
Die stellenanzeige liest sich so uninteressant für mich
Also wird da eh nicht hingehen aber das
Das liest sich auch nicht so als wird man sich da bewerben wollen
Okay damit damit wäre es endgültig
Damit wäre es für mich endgültig nicht mehr thema im leben nicht alter
Im leben nicht
Prinzip genau das gleiche oder hier sogar noch ein bisschen mehr
Finden die damit wirklich qualifizierte leute
Also geld sei jetzt auch nicht so geil aus aber okay ganz ohne krankenversicherung okay ja
Vielleicht was
Was haben wir denn hier noch zu bieten
Bechtle
Ist eine
Bring ich das jetzt durcheinander ist es sind bechtle nicht die
mit den tausend mobilen dienstleistern
mobilfunkdienstleistern
Oder bringe ich das jetzt durcheinander
Die wie 50 mobilfunkdienstleister haben die einfach unterschiedliche webseiten haben
Ne dann bringe ich das durcheinander
Wer steht denn hinter
Wie heißen die denn wen meine ich denn noch mal da
Wie heißt er noch mal wie heißt er noch mal
der anbieter hinter den
Diesen ganzen
retorten mobile anbietern
Trillisch die meine ich die meine ich genau das habe ich mir jetzt habe ich jetzt vertan ja die meine ich ja genau
Korrekt mit über 14.000 blablub
Gut ausbildung okay eine azubi stellenanzeige
Ausbildung zum fachinformatiker für systemintegration okay das was ich auch mal gelernt habe deine ausbildung startet am 1. august
Let's go würde ich sagen sicher viel zeit noch genau einen monat
Im mittelpunkt deiner ausbildung stehen die aufbau und anpassung von ja okay das klingt sinnig als physik
planung konflikt auch sinnvollen unterstützer
Okay, da hätte ich persönlich überhaupt null absolut null komma nix null sonst was bock drauf
Enduser support ich hatte glück ich musste nie nicht mal in meiner ausbildung enduser support machen
Wenn aber gut dass sie ausbilden weil sie die leute brauchen und die leute dann auch behalten wollen alles andere macht ja auch irgendwie keinen
Sinn kann sich nicht immer nur beschweren dass keine fachkräfte gibt und nicht ausbilden und sich immer weiter beschweren
Er gibt halt keinen sinn gehört dazu finde ich nicht ich musste das nie machen er hatte auch keinen bock drauf
Und ich würde das auch nicht machen wollen aber okay wenn es mal ab und zu ein paar
Keine ahnung zwei drei wochen irgendwie der gesamten ausbildung ist ja
Und der rest halt geil ist
Okay, also was was gibt es sonst noch
unser angebot modern work place
Du musst den leuten ja schon zur verfügung stellen dass sie ordentlich arbeiten können
vielseitig weiterbildung perspektive betreuung vergütung
das erwarte dich im
ehrlich gesagt liest sich mega 08 15 langweilig aber das muss nicht schlechtes sein was willst du was willst du auch bei
bei azubi
stellen anzeigen groß groß schreiben klar die könnten das durchaus mal ein bisschen
ansprechender gestalten aber das muss nicht schlecht sein
Ja azubis verdienen gar nicht so übel im vergleich also ich muss sagen ich habe in der ausbildung deutlich deutlich schlechter also auch
Inflationsbereinigte schlechter verdient aber gut ist ja auch angemessen dass man ein bisschen was rüber wachsen lässt
Ja kann ich ehrlich gesagt nicht nicht viel dazu sagen
Auch auch über die nicht ja ich kenne die vom namen her
Weiß dass die bei vielen sachen ihre finger mit dem spiel haben ich habe sie gerade verwechselt aber jetzt jetzt habe ich ja die zuordnung
Ja ich denke es schadet sicherlich nix das zu versuchen dort
Wer auch immer das gefragt hat
tschätzke wertwert ist noch mal
Ich kann ja leider nicht wirklich viel mehr dazu sagen wer sucht denn hier was bwi
dass das ist das
digital innovativ für die digitalisierung der bundeswehr oje ich meine denn ihre webseite sieht zumindest schon mal in irgendeiner art und weise
Modern aus zwar nicht so richtig nach bundeswehr aus aber immerhin ja es sieht es sieht modern aus
Was suchen sie denn senior it projektmanager näher gut was soll ich dazu sagen da habe ich überhaupt keine ahnung von
Sagt er nicht mit status geht es eigentlich mittlerweile wieder sie kontinuieren zu investigieren das issue
Jetzt aber heute ist ja wirklich ich habe es überhaupt nicht geplant dass wir heute stellen anzeigen
Stelz machen wir all sitting in one boat kann ich meine englisch skills hier wieder jetzt mal zum besten geben
Okay, every parking space will be digitalized was
Angeheuert recruiting okay das ist also irgendein
Personalvermittlung ding every physical barrier will be replaced with modern computer vision technology
Paper base
Und wie spricht man das aus es sind nicht recipes es sind
Rezepte und so was big touch okay
Es gibt
Recepts ja sie suchen ein senior back-end und der forbes engineer
tasks build up deep knowledge about our python based back-end services running on a
ws and
Edgedevices okay
Edgedevices auch schöne schöne ausdruck
chat
Ihr müsst jetzt nicht 30.000 anzeigen auf post
Aber gut ich meine warum eigentlich nicht wir machen das bis bis 22 30 oder so wenn genug da sind dann ist gut eigentlich
Wollte ich auch noch was anderes gucken aber es kommen auch die tage machen
Kann ich
Kalle wird
Front-end und machine learning engineers
Technical depth and evolve our infrastructure to support future requirements and meet our slh agreements
Ja, das ist nicht schlecht wenn man die slh die die slh ist packt weil dann uns kostet
Okay, und was was genau wollen die jetzt davon einem so genau
Okay requirements several years of experience you have already worked with pyson c++
C++ all da gehen wir plus weg
Like to switch to these languages alter im leben nicht der switch dann freiwillig zu c++
Okay ich ich verstehe warum sie c++ machen sie machen hauptsächlich python und dort wo das zu lahm ist
Machen sie halt immer die c++ module aber c++ leute
And believe in a child software development ich beliefe in in a child software development wenn ich mir genug zahl beliefe ich da in alles
You like to take responsibility
Interest iot area okay
Ein bisschen was anderes das aber auch zu dem was oben erzählt haben dass die
Papiersachen durch touchscreen ersetzen wollen also es passt schon dass sie was mit mit iot
machen
Okay, sie frontends wird mit erwitten in vue.js plus typescript. Okay, sieht man auch nicht so oft
Wobei ich sagen müsste view ist wahrscheinlich
hinter react und angular das beliebteste der frontend frameworks
Eventuell vielleicht in der masse sogar ein bisschen beliebter als angular aber im business enterprise umfeld bei den ganzen boomern ist
angular noch sehr beliebt
Backend python using flask
Sql chemie
Amazon s3
Wisst ihr übrigens für was s3 steht
Ist eigentlich ganz einfach wenn man es weiß aber ich glaube die wenigsten wissen es
Habe ich zumindest immer so den eindruck
Chetke s3
Sixer time wer weiß es
Sixer time
Secure storage
Simple storage service ja das richtig
Ich glaube es ist simple
Simple storage
Service
S3
Die stellenanzeige ist was für dich
Ich guck mal wie weit ich gleich komme
Noch im chat
AWS
Provisioned
Terraform
Kubernetes
Orchestration
Also das passt ja alles auf mich
Bloß die sache mit vue js und typescript
Und langjähriger python erfahrung
Und c++
Naja nicht wirklich
Fully remote
Okay das ist schonmal nice
Achso
Daily scrum muss man da sein
Ja gut wir sind ja super furchtbar agil
Ja
Ganz okay
Ich kann wenig dazu sagen gerade
Zu der geschichte
Das ist nicht so wirklich
Mein gebiet ja
Was haben wir hier denn
So 2 scrollen
Bad request gibt es nicht
Also lass mal schnell gucken
Was ist das hier
Kaffeebohnen Experte Softwareentwickler
Oh
Da haben wir welche die lustig sein wollen
Was sich jetzt schon
Instant abhebt von dem ganzen
Einheitsbrei
Auch wenn ich es vielleicht nicht so richtig lustig finde
Aber der gleiche kram
Kaffeebohnen Experte Softwareentwickler
Java
Du bist ein Tastenmagier und Kaffeebohnen Experte
Du zauberst Code
Wir kümmern uns um den Rest
Kurz und klagische Anzeige
Würde ich sagen
Leidenschaftliches Interesse
Handwerk Developer neugierig
Bereitschaft wieder neues
Erfahrung mit Programmiersprache Java
Cool fänden sie Kenntnisse im Umgang mit
Datenbanken
Microsoft
Oracle
Postgres
Kenntnisse in der Entwicklung
von Webbasierten
Javascript HTML
CSS
Ja ohne das wirst du dem Freund nicht weit kommen
Moderne
Entwicklungsmethoden
Scrum Continuous Integration
Test Driven Development
Sehr gute
Kurz und knackig
Ja
Ganz ehrlich
Sticht zumindest fast schon mehr raus
Als die anderen Sachen
Ich mein das ist halt jetzt wirklich nicht so geil
Ist ziemlich
Inhaltslos aber allein durch die Überschrift sticht es mehr raus
Als manch andere Sache
Trotzdem würde ich mich da nicht bewerben
Klingt nicht so überzeugend
Ausbildung
Logicali
Ist
Cloud und Automation
Storage und Virtualisierung
Backup und Recovery
Datenbank
Boah da gehts aber los
Volle Pulle
Wir vermitteln Kenntnisse
Architekturschwerpunkte sind Azure
Cloud, Red Hat, Linux
Hat man auf jeden Fall was ordentliches gelernt
Storage, Virtualisierung
Machen sie
NetApp
Dell
Backup
Recovery
Oracle
Business Enterprise
Netzwerk
Kohle
Einen kurzen Motivationsschreiben
Ja ich will nicht unter der Brücke schlafen
Ich brauch was zu essen
Ist das Motivation genug
Okay für einen Azubi kann man vielleicht noch
Bei einem Azubi finde ich es gar nicht mal so verkehrt
Dass du dann vielleicht noch mal
Die Leute
Dazu motivieren kannst
Warum sie Bock auf die Ausbildung haben
Ja
Klingt gar nicht so schlecht
Finde ich durchaus in Ordnung
Wenn ich eine Ausbildung suchen würde
Gut bei denen ist es nicht bei mir in der Nähe
Würde ich da ernsthaft drüber nachdenken
Macht doch
Gar keinen übelen Eindruck
Sie haben zumindest den Plan für die Ausbildung reingeschrieben
Finde ich dann schlecht
Vergleich mal eine deutsche Ausschreibung mit sowas
Cool
Infrastructure
Cloud
In Polen
Minimum Qualification
Bachelors Degree
Two years of experience with software development
in one or more programming languages
Advanced Degree
Two years of experience with data structures
Da musst du bestimmt den Binary Tree inverten
Beim Vorstellungsgespräch
Ähm
Two years of experience building and developing
Large Scale Infrastructure
Master's Degree
Preferred
Experience Developing
Accessibility
Das ist schön kurz und knackig
Right
Product
System Development
Code
Participate in or lead
Design Reviews
Ist auch ein bisschen vage
Aber es ist halt Google
Noch eine Ausbildung
Schlag auf Schlag
Oh die haben richtig richtig hippes Bild da oben
Richtig nice gefotoshopt
Ähm
Okay Aufbau von Wissen zum Umgang
MongoDB
Oder Postgres
Immer Postgres
Aber du kannst die zwei Sachen nicht vergleichen
Das eine ist eine NoSQL-Datenbank
Und Postgres ist eine Datenbank, die alles kann
Aber eigentlich im Kern immer noch ein relationales Datenbanksystem ist
Kommt auf deinen Anwendungsfall an
Aber ich würde sagen, wenn du nicht weißt, was du von beiden nehmen sollst
Dann willst du wahrscheinlich Postgres nehmen
Aufbau von Wissen zum Umgang mit Techniken
Mit Techniken
Wie Bash
Was suchen die?
Okay
Bash, Python, Debian-Paketierung
Alter gibt noch Leute, die Debian-Packages bauen
OpenLDAP-Active-Directory
Aktuellen Netztechnologien
Und vielen anderen modernen Linux-
Das klingt doch gar nicht mal so übel
Das klingt gar nicht mal so schlecht
Kennenlernen des gesamten Arbeitsablaufs
Beratung, Konzeption, Test, Dokumentation
Ja bla bla
Unterstützen
Okay das heißt Endkunden
Telefonsupport
Hör mal doch auf alter
Regelmäßige Azubi und 1 zu 1 treffen
Mit deinem Mentor
Das kann gut oder schlecht sein
Ich tendiere mal eher zu nervig
Umgang mit Menschen und Technik
Also die meisten Leute, die ich kenne
Haben entweder Bock auf Umgang mit Menschen
Oder Bock auf Umgang mit Technik
Es gibt wenig Leute, die Bock auf Technik
Und Umgang mit Menschen haben
Linux
Hohe Spaßarbeit im Team
Flexible Arbeitszeiten
Fehlt ein Hackathon
An so einem Ding habe ich auch mal mitgemacht
Auf der alten Arbeit
Und es hat am Ende der gewonnen
Der nur eine gute Präsentation
Gehalten hat und 3 Tage
Sich auf die Präsentation vorbereitet hat
Versus die, die tatsächlich eine App gebaut haben
Naja gut
Deine Gesundheit liegt uns am Herzen
Dazu bezuschusten wir Sportaktivität
Und
Quali
Train
Und dein Dienstrad
Ja, finde ich auch gar nicht so übel
Klingt eigentlich ganz gut
Ja, ist auch so
Korrekt, du kannst mit Postgres
Nahezu alles machen
Aber wenn es um reines neues QL
Geschichten geht, ist MongoDB
Sicherlich die bessere Wahl
Aber wenn man sich nicht sicher ist, was man haben will
Dann höchstwahrscheinlich Postgres
Noch was aus der Schweiz
Oh ne
Duales Studium
Ne, das kann ich mir nicht angucken
Das ist das letzte, was wir uns heute angucken
Übrigens, danke für die ganzen Subs
Leute
Also, wow
Irgendwie finde ich das Bild bescheuert
Ich kann nicht genau beschreiben warum
Aber irgendwie finde ich das Bild bescheuert
Okay
Die Versicherungskammer in
München
Ein Senior Fullstack Softwareentwickler
Java in München
Alles klar
Ihr Zukunft ist unser Programm
Wertschätzung, Sicherheit
Euer Programm ist erstmal eure Zukunft
Dafür steht der Konzern
Versicherungskammer und sein IT-Unternehmen
VK
Bitbetrieb GMEH
Java und Java Enterprise
Angular, SQL, Spring
REST und Scrums
Oh, Safe
Die sind mal mit Safe am Start jetzt
Aber ob die auch
Lean sind, ist die Frage
Meint ihr, die sind auch Lean?
Lean genug?
Äh, kennen sie so gut wie
die Namen ihrer Freun- Joa
Ich mein, hey, ich bin kein Java-Entwickler und sogar ich kenne den Kram
Was ist denn
Das ist so ein bisschen was in die Richtung
Ich will jetzt nicht sagen, wie
ITIL, das trifft's nicht so ganz
Das ist so ne
Wie nennt man das?
So ne Projektmethodik? Nee, nicht Projekt
Was sagen die denn offiziell dazu?
Scaled Agile Framework
Besteht aus einer Reihe von Organisationen
und Workflow-Mustern zu implementieren
Ja, das ist so ne
Guideline-Geschichten für wie man
coole, agile Software entwickelt
Da gibt es noch mehr in der Richtung
Lean gibt es auch noch
Lean Agile
Und solche Geschichten
Wunderbar
Wunderbar, damit können sie
unsere neue Software
und Experte
für unsere Betriebssysteme auf Java
Vertriebssysteme auf Java-Basis sein
Sie arbeiten gerne
in agilen Teams und begleiten
gewissenhaft Aufgaben von Kompetition bis zur Realisierung
und bieten ihnen Position
Bla bla bla bla
Das haben sie vor
So
Sie entwerfen und entwickeln
Softwarelösungen in der
breiten Systemlandschaft
für den Vertrieb des Konzerns
Ja gut, das dachte ich mir
wenn ihr nen Softwareentwickler sucht
Sie definieren
gemeinsam mit dem Team die technische
Architektur unserer Softwarelandschaft
gestalten aktiv die Zukunft dieser
Das sind so
Residenz-Lieber diese Sätze immer
Leute ich werde richtig
müde
ich bekomme da so richtig Sand
in den Augen
wenn ich diese Sätze lesen muss
Das ist alles immer so ultra langweilig
geschrieben
Letztens hatten wir noch ne coole Stellenanzeige
mit den Emojis drin
Das hat mich viel mehr angesprochen als sowas hier
Hier hat irgendwie einer
ne Powerpointfolie als HTML
gerendert und auf die Webseite gestellt
Wahrscheinlich wirklich
Wollen wir mal gucken
Durchaus möglich
Also
Okay wahrscheinlich ist es kein
Powerpoint Export aber
Wobei
Oh
Modalstructure ist das WordPress?
Mediawiki
Moment
Das ist ein Mediawiki
Ist ein Mediawiki
Aber was anderes
Sie nutzen innovative Technologien wie
Also
Ich würde Angular nicht unbedingt als sonderlich innovativ
in diesem Bereich einschätzen
Angular ist quasi so das
Kobol der Frontend Frameworks
Angular Spring
REST Services
Na gut das stimmt nicht Kobol ist alt
Ich meinte eher den Business Aspekt von Kobol
Angular Spring
REST Services, Microservices
in der Front- und Backend Entwicklung
Um die bestehenden
Blablabla
Im kollegialen Umfeld
Wie oft haben wir das denn jetzt schon
die letzten Tage gelesen
Sie nutzen Freiräume und bringen eigene Ideen
Sie warten und betreuen die erstellten
Lösungstechnologien
Das ist so Resident Sleeper
Okay
Spring
Angular
Erfahrung in der Softwareentwicklung
IBM DB2
Ach du Scheiße
Womöglich läuft das
Alles auf einem IBM Host
Großrechner
Praktische Kenntnisse
von modernen Software
Architekturkonzept
Analytische und konzeptionelle
Fähigkeiten
Scrum
Save
Das bieten wir
Zukunftssicher Arbeitsplatz
Spannende Projekte
Ja das sagen sie alle
Die Möglichkeit mobil zu arbeiten
Ja
Frage ist halt
Ob ihr das auch wirklich macht
Oder ob es dann so heißt
Ja alle 2 Wochen
Kannste mal ein Tag daheim bleiben
Interesse
Dann
Boah das ist ja
Seriously
Ich fand die super langweilig
Die Anzeige
Ich weiß nicht
Chat wie seht ihr das
Die war nicht mal lustig
Schlecht oder so
Die war einfach nur
Total generic 0815
Langweilig
Wer verwendet auch
DB2
Ich glaub wir haben auf der Arbeit
Irgendwo auch noch DB2
Kann man überhaupt noch
Irgendwo in nicht agilen Teams einsteigen
Ja mit Sicherheit
Zum Beispiel bei der lokalen
Frag mich nicht
Keine Ahnung
Bei der lokalen Autovermietung
Klitsche oder so
Gibt sicherlich noch genug
Wo da nichts mit Agilität ist
Und viele von denen die sagen
Dass sie agil sind, sind ja absolut nicht agil
Kommt ja auch noch dabei
Nee kann ich nicht
Weil
Ich sag euch jetzt auch warum ich keine Leute mehr grüße
Ich kann Patrick grüßen wenn du willst
Moin Patrick
Aber ich kann nicht die Kombination aus Vor- und Nachnamen grüßen
Es liegt daran
Ja Chainlord ich kann nicht grüßen
Wobei ich sag nicht woran das liegt
Sonst gibt es noch mehr Gbade Versuche
War das mal ein Bewerbungsgespräch bei der
Schuhfahrer, die an wen für Devops
gesucht meinten, aber dass man bei denen
das nicht Devops nennen darf
Und warum?
Was ist eigentlich dein Tipp
Wenn man sagen würde
Dass man ziemlich was drauf hat
Aber keine Interviews in die
Firmen bekommt die man eigentlich gerne
Ja das würde ich mir erstmal überlegen, warum
Nicht
Also da gibt es ja
Vielleicht Gründe, ich mein die sagen ungern was
Das stimmt schon
Meistens sind die Absagen immer super generic
Aber vielleicht kommst du ja irgendwie ein bisschen dahinter
Ähm
Und dann ist halt auch die Frage
Wer sagt, dass man super was drauf hat
Ich mein von sich selbst
Denkt man das halt immer gerne
Oder aber auch nicht, es gibt ja eher so zwei Lager
Welche die richtig was können und nicht
Oder welche die es nicht so richtig drauf haben
Aber denken, dass sie es ultra drauf haben
Also ich würde erstmal drauf warten, dass mir irgendjemand anderes sagt
Dass ich es ultra drauf habe, bevor ich irgendwann anfange
Selbst zu glauben
Ähm
Aber ansonsten
Wo willst du denn hin zum Beispiel, wo das nicht wird
Also
Wahrscheinlich die üblichen Verdächtigen
Willst du zu Microsoft oder Google
Ja gut, die können sich halt
Die Bewerber aussuchen
Wobei ich nicht weiß
Ob das immer noch der Fall ist, ja
Also da werden sich sicherlich mehr bewerben
Als bei der 015 Klitsche um die Ecke
Aber ob da immer noch die hunderten Leute
Schlange stehen, weiß ich gar nicht
Ja also warum du keine Antwort drauf kriegst
Das kann ich dir nicht sagen
Das kann ich jetzt auch schlecht wissen
Also
Okay, ich kann dir, ich geb dir nen Tipp
Guck, dass du ein Gitterprofil hast
Mit was drinne
Mit ordentlich was drinne
Also sprich
Dass du was kannst
Ja
Also Gitterprofil ist auf jeden Fall
Egal wo du dich bewirbst in der heutigen Zeit
Immer nicht schlecht
Sogar ich hatte ein Gitterprofil drin
Und ich hab mich nicht primär als Anwendungsentwickler beworben
Aber ich hatte auch mal ein Gitterprofil drinne
Und das war sogar
Kurzzeitig Gespräch
Gesprächsthema
Beim Vorstellungsgespräch vor Ort
Also
Da ging es kurz um Software auf meinem
Also Gitterprofil
Mit ein paar Projekten drinne
Wo man halt so ungefähr sieht
Was du so treibst
Und was du so kannst
Ist sicherlich nicht verkehrt
Aber das ist der einzige Tipp, den ich dir jetzt so geben kann
Sonst ist es so
Kaffeesatzleserei
So ein Profil neben einem Vollzeitjob aufzubauen
Der hat ja keinen Vollzeitjob
Der geht ja nur Vollzeit studieren
Naja das stimmt schon
Aber es muss jetzt ja auch nicht irgendwie
Du musst ja nicht TempelOS bauen
Du kannst ja kein eigenes OS bauen
Aber wenn du dich mit Technologien auskennst
Ist es ja auch
Also wenn du wirklich Ahnung hast
Ist es ja auch relativ easy
Vielleicht die ein oder andere Demoanwendung
Raufzuladen
Dass man schon mal gucken kann
Okay der bewirbt sich als Frontendentwickler
Wie sieht denn das aus, wenn der so Javascript von sich gibt
Ja
Das stimmt
Letztendlich kannst du
Du kannst da nicht so wirklich was drauf geben
Die haben eindeutig eher sowas gesucht
Anstatt ein Softwareentwickler
Aber gut
Letztendlich ist das alles auch sehr im Fluss
Und jeder legt es ein bisschen anders aus
Viele bewerben sich nicht
Du meinst jetzt bei Google
Viele gute bewerben sich nicht, weil sie denken, sie werden nicht genommen
Also ich hab mich schon
Ab und zu mal Gedanken drüber gemacht
Also nicht mich wirklich dort zu bewerben
Sondern
Aber ich bin immer so generell
Irgendwie sagt mir das
Von alledem, was man so
Von Leuten, die dort gearbeitet haben
Sagt mir das nicht wirklich
Also hat mich das nicht wirklich
Dahin gezogen
Mir da auch nochmal ernsthaft Gedanken drüber zu machen
Weil
Erstens was mich abschreckt
Viele Leute stellen fest, nachdem sie dort angefangen haben
Ich glaube im Durchschnitt bleiben die Leute ja nur eineinhalb Jahre da
Und stellen fest
Es ist doch nicht das, was sie sich vorgestellt haben
Also ich stelle mir Google
Auch viele der großen IT
Top
Player
Stelle ich mir die Arbeitsatmosphäre
Und die Umgebung gar nicht so cool vor
Wie das vielleicht immer beworben wird
Also es
Es wirkt ja auch in diesen
One day in the life of a software developer
Und sowas wirkt es ja auch immer
Die gehen da hin, sind alle super gut drauf
Sind alle voll dicke
Aber in Wirklichkeit ist es wahrscheinlich Arbeiten
Wenn du da auch noch wohnst
Wahrscheinlich bis es dunkel ist
Du bist den ganzen Tag dort
Machst vielleicht Pause
Indem du dort in irgendeinen Fitnessraum gehst
Oder sowas
Bis den ganzen Tag dort
Gehst erst nach 20 oder so wirklich
Oder teilweise 21 Uhr in die Wohnung
Und dieses ganze System mit
Du kriegst gleich irgendeinen Performance Coaching
Wenn mal irgendwas nicht so gelaufen ist
Oder
Die Leute gucken untereinander
So quasi
Wie man möglichst gut
Nur eigene Erfolge verkaufen kann
Und andere Leute irgendwie ausstechen kann
Und sowas
Ich weiß nicht das ist irgendwie nix
Was mich da hingezogen hätte
Ich weiß nicht
Es kann natürlich auch alles total übertrieben sein
Weiß nicht ob es wirklich so ist
Aber es gibt halt schon gewisse
Tendenzen
Wenn man sich die Beschreibung durchliest
Von Leuten die mal bei Google
Oder so gearbeitet haben
Oder Facebook
Das das eher sowas
Entweder du gehst halt voll auf
In dieser
Oder sag mal so
Du lässt dich komplett
Verschlucken
Von dieser jeweiligen Kultur
Die dort herrscht
Oder du hast halt gelitten
Ja gut Amazon ist ja noch
Da würde ich noch
Unliebsamer hin
Oder noch ungerner hin
Und Facebook und sowas
Also von den Großen
Das gibt schon ein recht
Konsistentes Bild in dieser Richtung
Wenn man sich Berichte durchliest
Von Leuten
Und es hat ja auch seinen Grund
Dass gerade bei Google glaube ich ist es
Dass die Leute ja wohl im Durchschnitt
Nur eineinhalb Jahre da sind
Die dort neu anfangen
Also das ist echt nix worauf ich Bock hätte
Ja hab ich gespielt
Sogar die ganzen Playtests
Nicht alle
Was ist das Äquivalent zu GitHub?
Ist das Admins
GitHub
GitHub ist GitHub
Nein
Man verwendet GitHub
Wenn man
Sowas haben will wie GitHub
Egal ob man jetzt ein Softwareentwickler ist
Oder Admin ist man verwendet GitHub
Ach du meinst
Achso GitHub Link
In der Bewerbung ja auch GitHub Link
Wobei es vielleicht bei
Wenn du dich wirklich auf so ne klassische Admin Stelle bewirbst
Vielleicht nicht so
Relevant ist wie wenn du dich als Entwickler bewirbst
Aber auch ja
Kann man durchaus machen
GitHub
Ich hatte in meiner
Leute ich hab mich auch nicht
Ich arbeite ja nicht
Hab ich euch ja schon erzählt
Ja auch wenn wir hier oftmals
Bisschen was Richtung Softwareentwicklung programmieren machen
Im Stream
Und
Ich hab auch ein GitHub
In meine Bewerbung
Mein GitHub Profil in die Bewerbung gepackt
Ich hatte da sogar
Kubernetes
Und Ansible Sachen drin
Aber es ging im Vorstellungsgespräch
Tatsächlich nicht darum
Sondern um ein Softwareprojekt
Auf meinem GitHub Account
Ich weiß nicht mal was das sein soll
Keine Ahnung was das überhaupt sein soll
What
Im Bereich Defense
Keine Ahnung
Wenn die ordentlich bezahlen
Und davon ausgehen kannst
Dass das was du für Defense machst
Wahrscheinlich auch für Offense genutzt werden kann
Wenn ich das nicht juckt in die ordentlich bezahlen
Warum nicht
Ja du brauchst ja für solche Beispielprojekte
Gar nichts irgendwie noch nie dagewesenes
Du kannst auch durchaus irgendwas bauen
Was es schon gibt
Einfach dass man sieht
Du bewirbst dich als
Einfach mal sieht wie sieht denn dein Java Zeug so aus
Vielleicht nicht unbedingt eine To-Do App
Aber irgendwas in dieser Richtung
Oder wenn du dich bewirbst
Als Frontend Entwickler
Schwerpunkt
React
Und hast dann halt mal
Ein React das sie sich zumindest mal angucken können
Ja
JavaScript TypeScript
Wie sieht dein React Code so aus
Also ich denke
Das ist tatsächlich echt der einzige Tipp den ich dir geben kann
Das ist praktisch dafür
Du hostest dein eigenes Homelab
Aber wie kann man das in der Bewerbung zeigen
Da muss man ein bisschen kreativ werden
Ich mein
Was du machen kannst ist
Du kannst es natürlich erwähnen
Bei irgendwelchen
In jedem Abschnitt wo es passt
Ich mein
Du kannst auch dein GitHub verlinken
Und dort unter Projekte
Beispielsweise
Was auch immer du verwendest
Für dein Homelab zum Aufsetzen
Oder Scripts von deinem Homelab
Was auch immer
Kannst du in dein GitHub Profil packen
Da irgendwie keine Ahnung
Da bin ich auch
Da bin ich selbst auch sehr unkreativ
Wie gesagt ich mache in dem nächsten Video
Wo ich euch mal meine Bewerbung zeige
Und Skills und Lebenslauf und alles
Da könnt ihr sehen wie ich das gemacht hab
Und es ist bei mir ein bisschen wie beim PC kaufen
Ich kenne mich mit aktueller Desktop Hardware
Aus wo ich sie mir kaufe
D.h. nachdem bei mir jetzt Bewerbungssachen und so durch sind
Hab ich so komplett das Mindset
Dafür verloren und bin auch unkreativ
Mir was auszudenken
Großkonzerne sind nur was zum Grinden
Warum? Ich arbeite auch bei einem Großkonzern
Hab davor auch bei einem Großkonzern gearbeitet
Gut, ich weiß nicht wie Großkonzern definiert ist
Vielleicht auch nicht
Also ich glaube nicht dass wir
Irgendwie mehr als
50.000 sind oder sowas
Aber es sind schon nicht wenig
Die bezahlen wenigstens pünktlich
Und die gibt's morgen auch noch
Und die bezahlen auch nicht schlecht
Die können sich's leisten zum größten Teil
Muss nicht schlecht sein
Und ich hab überhaupt keine Karriere
Cry in Absicht
Ja ich hab schon Battle Build Remaster gespielt
Ja
Mir wär's lieber als Windows aufm Notebook
Aber gut ich hab ja auch
Meine Linux VM auf der ich root bin
Glücklicherweise
Also ich hab recht viel Abwechslung aktuell
Also das ist
Das kann man so pauschal nicht sagen
Also ich bin aktuell in einem Projekt mit dabei
Zum größten Teil
Was fast nur Cloud gedöhnt ist
Von Terraform
Ansible, Kubernetes
Und halt viel Linux Zeug
Und wir haben auch noch genug On-Prem
Geschichten
Die so tatsächlich speziell
Und Oldschool sind oftmals
Dass da kaum noch einer durchblickt
Also ich find das aktuell wirklich nice
Das wechseln hat sich echt gelohnt
Also jetzt nicht nur für die Kohle
Und die bessere Homeoffice Regel
Auch drum herum find ich das wirklich nice
Mal was anderes zu machen
Also halt nix wo sich ein bisschen eingefahren hat
Was man so macht
Auch wenn es rein von den Themen her recht ähnlich ist
Zu halten Arbeit
Würdest du im Ausland arbeiten wollen?
Mal gute Entlohnung?
Nö, kein Bock
Da muss man so viele neue Leute kennenlernen
Und neue Leute sich arrangieren
Keine Ahnung
Ich weiß, ich weiß
Ich hab grad keinen Bock was dran weiterzumachen
Das funktioniert für meine Zwecke gut genug
Und ich müsste das eigentlich noch ein bisschen
Architekturtechnisch überarbeiten
Dass ich da zum Beispiel
Die MQTT Notifications von Amazon
Gescheit einbauen kann
Oder auch mehrere
Accounts unterstützen kann
Sinnvoll
Ist auf jeden Fall besser als nix
Ja das hab ich auch irgendwo gelesen
Lohnt es sich nach einer fachinformatiker Ausbildung zu studieren?
Ne warum?
Also was ist der Grund warum du studieren willst?
Also einfach nur studieren
Um das Studieren Willens
Macht keinen Sinn
Wenn du Geld verdienen willst
Kannst du es mit deiner Ausbildung genauso machen
Musst nicht studieren für
Musst halt was können
Und auf die Reihe kriegen
Nö
Ich mein vielleicht außer es hat einen Grund warum du studieren willst
Einfach nur studieren
Macht keinen Sinn
Beste
Das war ich nicht
Alles klar
Es ging nicht darum ob Ausbildung oder Studium
Es ging darum ob man nach der Ausbildung noch ein Studium machen soll
Das war die Frage
Nicht ob Ausbildung oder Studium
Bad getimed
Leute
Ich guck jetzt noch ein bisschen stream oder so
Und dann geh ich pennen
Wir sehen uns morgen früh
Wie gehabt
Zwischen 8 und 9
Zwischen 8 und 30
Aufwachen
Stream am Start
Und demnächst müssen wir auch wieder
Irgendwas Nices basteln
Ne hab ich noch nicht ganz durchgeguckt
Guck ich vielleicht jetzt noch fertig
Ich glaub ich bin jetzt so bei
6 Folgen hat das oder so
Der mittlere Part
Ist ein bisschen lahmarschig
Die ersten 2-2,5 Folgen
Waren mega nice
Jetzt passiert nicht mehr so wirklich was
LPig zu kaufen
Wenn es seine Arbeit gäbe
Aber zahlen würde ich es machen
Ihr wisst ich bin kein großer Fan
Von irgendwelchen Zertifikaten
Okay Leute ich geh ins Bett
Bis morgen früh machts gut